and at this time I'd just like to h
stand and have a moment of silence for
Barbara thank you very
much with that we're at our time we need
to go ahead and start it is 9:30 right
now
and we will move through our docket uh
in the order that bills have been put
forward and the first bill is HB
1218 I happen to be the prime sponsor of
that bill so I will set aside and go to
the testifying table and uh represent
cordelli will continue this uh this
meeting or this
hearing thank you Mr chairman uh so we
will open the uh public hearing on House
Bill
1218 relative to the merger of Granite
State College with the University of New
Hampshire and uh with that I will call
upon the uh Prime sponsor uh
representative lad uh to uh open
testimony
thank you very much Mr chairman and it's
kind of weird looking at this Maze of
tables and chairs in front of us for the
record my name is Rick lad I come from
hail H New
Hampshire and I also am uh the
representative of our speaker as a
trustee uh in the University system New
Hampshire I'm here today to introduce uh
HB 1218
this bill is a bill that deals with the
merger of Granite State College into the
University New
Hampshire uh during the first part of
the last
year we had a lot of discussion on this
committee regarding the merger of the
community college system and the
university system New
Hampshire and a number of issues were
brought forward at that time by folks
from both both uh the associates degree
level the uh the seven community
colleges and the university system with
at that time the four uh uh locations
actually we have more locations with
Manchester and
Conquer but there are some existential
threats facing higher education today we
have a shrinking enrollment not just in
New Hampshire but New England and the
country and postsecondary education
chasing the same students not just in
our of all institutions throughout this
country in New England are chasing the
same demographic that is
shrinking just in the state of New
Hampshire alone in 2003 we had a student
population K through 12 of 28,000
students in
2021 it shrunk to 169,000 students a
loss of 39,000 students you can see the
implications we have when that comes to
uh students preparing to leave high
school and go on to the postsecondary
level we also see within both uh systems
you University system the community
college system Capital costs are
increasing new renovation maintenance
projects um and replacement of some of
that uh Capital cost are huge and the
operational expenses vers the revenues
are at margin at best it's extremely
tight margin and we need to be looking
at the whole system how we operate our
postsecondary system we have campuses
that have overbuilt in many cases for a
population that no longer exists labor
and benefits is
increasing and we have many uni unique
student needs which need to be addressed
in light of the workforce needs in our
state
today the successes that these two
systems have are are a large number they
have been working closely the
chancellors have worked closely to merge
and try to look at efficiencies in terms
of purchasing powers and terms of
operational
costs the M we they we have also tried
to maintain the unique missions of the
two
systems they are very different but but
they also have paralleling needs that
overlap and we got to be looking at that
the the systems to this point are very
Nimble and adapted to changing Workforce
needs we have done that the system
chancellors as I said before have looked
at various curriculum agreements
accreditation process joint efficiencies
Etc we found on that subcommittee that
we worked back in March 19 2021 we gave
a report to the finance division 2
regarding the concept of merging the two
systems together we saw issues
associated with governance affordability
accessibility vision for postsecondary
Education New
Hampshire strategic planning
institutional mission and vision heard
from we heard from Nei New England
Commission of higher
education we also have got involved from
the public uh higher public education
committee perspective the legislature
was involved
and we came out with some
recommendations from that subcommittee
where go slow get this thing right to
achieve desired
results and work with the public higher
education study committee since then we
have looked at and the trustees have
looked at of the University system New
Hampshire how we can start this road
towards more efficiencies and merging
our
systems the university system TR
trustees have looked looked Inward and
they see that there is tremendous
potential in combining our merging
Granite State College with UNH
Manchester there are some real true
benefits to that the bill
accomplishes um a comp uniting
complimentary mission statements the
online programs at at are are uh Keen
State Plymouth State Granite State and
UNH into one uh one system
um marketing potential for use uh for
Granite State really magnifies when we
put it on the umbrella of the University
of New Hampshire so with this this bill
we are proposing that the Granite State
College become a college within the
University of New
Hampshire the president of Granite State
College is now the chancellor of the
community college system New Hampshire
we have Jim Dean who is the president of
the University of New Hampshire now
president of the college within the
University of New Hampshire Granite
State
college students currently in Granite
State College in un Manchester will be
able to complete their programs of
study as they are set up right
now but this whole proposal really
leverages the strengths and resources of
both campuses in support of all of the
four-year systems we have or colleges we
have here in University Kean Clem State
and
UNH there's expense savings from
facilities lease and space
utilization it's in sh it's an enhanced
shared undergraduate Pathways within the
community college system in University
of New Hampshire system New Hampshire in
short we have taken this bill before the
public higher education committee had
unanimous support from them that's a
committee made up of senators and uh
Representatives that worked between the
community college system and University
system and understand the missions of
both so there's unanimous support there
there's un unanimous support from the
trustees to move in this
direction yes we are looking at more and
more uh options and efficiencies and
paths to take this is the initial path
and I would hope that you support this
bill which will uh strengthen our
University system college system in the
state of New Hampshire thank you very
much thank you does the committee have
any questions for representative
lad
yes thank you very thank you very much
Mr chair thank you um representative lad
for um for for bringing this um this
very strong very bipartisan bill of
forward to us this morning um just
always like to hear uh if you know um uh
what may have surfaced if there were any
uh risks identified by any of the
parties or any of the groups like the uh
public higher education study uh
committee or the um or the um uh
trustees at the University system in
terms of uh uh this merger and uh the um
uh the continuation of Granite State
College being able to continue
delivering on its
Mission thank you very much for the
question uh when this uh proposed
legislation was submitted to the public
higher education commission and I don't
know if Senator Ward's here or not she
chairs it I know representa umberger is
also on that and a number of us are uh
yes there was there were there was
discussion
regarding missions and where we're going
with this entire process um that is of
course not really associated with this
particular Bill however there was
concern echoed by a number of folks that
we want to make sure that we preserve
the unique mission of the community
college system and the missions of the
uh four-year schools that we respect the
advancements and the pathways that have
been developed by the community college
ship uh system towards uh career
Pathways certification programs Etc in
those skill areas and that one system
doesn't start jumping in and saying well
we're going to get involved in this and
stepping on somebody else's Turf this is
one of the reasons why mergers have to
occur we have to start looking at for
example the accomplishment that's just
been done with Plymouth State University
and White Mountain Community College
where a student that comes out when
associates degree from White Mountain
Community College will enter Plymouth
State University as a junior no question
you will enter as a
junior that will save a huge amount of
money in the part of our our students
that are having to pay and afford
College educations which is exorbitant
to begin with so there's a cost savings
there but it's also uh an efficiency
program where we have to start working
closely together I think that's the
ultimate goal here is for us to develop
a postsecondary system here in New
Hampshire that has these efficiencies
understands we have a shrinking
demographic and we have Capital cost
these campuses they're just climbing
beyond what we can really achieve in
some of the maintenance in these
buildings especially the community
college system we need to throw more
maintenance dollars at so uh there was
discussion on that representative luno
um uh I think that much that will come
out there in subsequent bills which we
have coming forward and in substance uh
discussion uh uh held by that public
higher education
committee you're welcome thank you very
much glad to hear that there was
consideration for that
thanks thank you uh representative
wck thank you Mr chairman I appreciate
it represent thank you for taking my
question one is a question be all right
a clarification as well so granted State
College would by understand what you're
saying would be
absorbed basically like a satellite or a
division in UNH that's my first question
it will be part of the UN University of
New Hampshire
Manchester and underneath the umbrella
of unh now for further Clarity on that I
know that we have the chancellor for the
University system sitting behind me
Kathy uh proventure is here and there
will be folks that will be speaking on
this as well and perhaps and Woodcock
that might be a better question to
direct to the people that are directly
involved with it okay thank you follow
Mr chair thank you represent Celli just
just one for General edification um
currently the Plymouth if I understand
this correctly Plymouth and Keane uh are
independent Operator schools is there a
plan to have UNH as the umbrella in the
future take all these in see I I think
that that's that's a step that's down
the road
ways right now the those three schools
that you talked about pet ke and UNH
separate body politic corporate body bch
so they report directly to the
trustees and they don't report to each
other um the moves the directions we got
to go in looking at higher education in
the state is that we got to get out of
the silo effect we got to get out of the
effect that each school is separate and
a separate corporate body politic and we
will decide what courses we accept what
we don't accept um if you look at the
Penn State system where there's over 20
uh
locations course 101 on the western side
of the core state is accepted on the
Eastern side of the state same course
and there's no no squabbling or fighting
between these various campuses um we're
going in that direction and we need to
uh so that's a good question and it's
one that needs more resolution and and
and and and insight in from the the the
uh presidents of the schools and the
folks working within it how we can
arrive at a point where that there is a
we can't compare the community college
system to the university system
Chancellor that the chancellor of the
community college system the president's
report directly to the chancellor that's
not the case in the University system
the president's report to the trustees
two different animals and so um I hope
to see us really get on top of this and
develop a a goal a flight path to get us
set to that end result with benchmarks
along the way which uh really uh improve
and recognize what we have to do in the
state to continue to maintain a first
class higher education system thank you
represent thank you Mr chairman thank
you
are there any other uh
questions seen none thank you very much
thank you and uh next we have Kathy
proventure and Mike delli um hope I Dell
yes thank
you uh good morning uh Mr chairman and
members of the committee can you hear me
okay uh for the record my name is
Katherine preventure um uh thank you
representative Vlad I am not the
chancellor uh I am actually the chief
administrative officer the the board has
for now decides to keep the chancellor
role vacant I um have assumed all the
administrative responsibilities of the
chancellor position so again my name is
Kathy preventure I serve as the chief
administrative officer and the vice
Chancellor of Finance for our state's
University system and uh pleased to be
here this morning and very much
appreciate representative lad's comments
we also appreciate the the support of
the entire public higher ed study
committee in um thinking through this
this merger of granted State College
into the University of New
Hampshire um as you well know uh and as
representative lad has articulated
higher education especially in the
Northeast is facing some very
significant headwinds over the next 3 to
five years because of demographics
because of changing student demands and
um when the president of granted State
College Mark Rubenstein U took on their
role of Chancellor of the community
college system our board and our
presidents really took the opportunity
to think how could we think about this
differently in the future at every at
every turn we're we're we're trying to
think through that uh granted State
College and the University of Manchester
University of um New Hampshire and
Manchester have many similar
programs also granted state college has
the the infrastructure or the backbone
for online delivery the University of
New Hampshire had some of that as well
so there was a duplication of effort
there so the decision was made to come
forward with legislation to merge
granted State College into the
University of New Hampshire
um Dean Dell
is
oh I'm
sorry so
um I will say I will say you know
another risk could be we want to make
sure we keep the community college
system very much informed because um
Granite State uh Granite State College
is a big receiver of community college
students so we are um I met with
Chancellor Rubenstein I think last week
or the week before we're making sure
that we keep the community college
system informed the community college
and university system we have a work a
working group that meets periodically on
a number of areas that we can
collaborate our next meeting is this
afternoon Dean Dell is going to brief
that whole group on um efforts in moving
moving in in this
direction um I would say uh another risk
is uh we don't act quickly enough on a
number of fronts understanding what is
in front of higher education in the
Northeast in the coming years
and what's always a risk is is culture
and we have to um make sure that we're
aware of that and and keep folks
appropriately
informed U we're we're committed to
preserving the name Granite State
College because it's important to the
alumni of granted State College and
we're also committed to
um ensuring that I mentioned this we're
mindful of the Open Access and
reasonable price point
for for our Granite Staters who attend
Granite State College um we were asked a
question when we are at public hire and
study committee we've included this in
the testimony um we do not anticipate
any forced layoffs because of this
merger and um with that um oh I also
wanted to um follow up on a question
from representative Woodcock there are
no plans being discussed right now to
have keen state or pus State absorbed
into the University of New Hampshire
we're trying to think how to get ahead
of the
headwinds and in doing so ensure we keep
the mission and the uniqueness of keing
State College clou State University the
University of New Hampshire they are
important parts of the regions of our
state of the badok region in the North
Country there are lots of conversations
and plans um being developed in the
University system of New Hampshire to
share the resources across those
campuses but there are no plans
for I I'll use the word absorption or
merger with those
institutions I don't know if if uh
Dean uh would you like to have the dean
speak next and then take questions or
would you like to take uh questions
right now
Kathy I I'd like to give Dean Dell an
opportunity just to give you just an
overview of the work that's already
happening with Granite State College and
and UNH Manchester that's thank you then
go ahead
please uh good morning and thanks for
inviting me here to uh talk with you all
uh this morning uh so um just by way of
background um I have been uh at UNH for
now almost uh six years have having uh
joined uh UNH from actually a long
career in the technology industry uh
including leading several uh small
private companies so I am very familiar
with the risks the opportunities
presented by uh mergers um like this um
I would characterize uh the work so far
as going extremely well we have a large
number of individuals from both Granite
State College and un age engaged in what
is very very complex and detailed
planning efforts um these are in some
ways similar schools because as our
testimony uh indicates um we do um serve
in some sense uh many of the same types
of students especially in the greater
Manchester area but in other senses we
have uh very complimentary uh student
markets uh UNH Manchester has extensive
physical infrastructure that serves
students especially in the Sciences in
the engineering fields and so we are
bringing together schools that have
similarities but also in some cases uh
significant uh differences uh the two
institutions have different academic
calendars we have different admission
standards as uh uh Kathy indicated we
have different tuition price points and
it is so critical to preserve what is
good about each institution while
benefiting from the synergies that
bringing the two uh institutions
together uh can uh deliver um I do want
to talk about risk so for me the risks
that I think about are execution risk um
we have the same people planning this
merger as um are continuing to operate
their individual institutions so it's
very important that we not lose focus on
the students we are currently serving in
the the way we are serving them as we
implement this merger and I think we're
taking very very careful steps uh to
make sure that we are not injuring
either School while we're implementing
what we believe is the best course for
the collective institution uh going
forward so I'm quite happy uh with the
work that we're doing we have already
taken steps on physical
infrastructure for example the 25 Hall
Street location which is graned State's
headquarters um is largely now leased
out um we occupy just now a small
fraction of that building having leased
the second and third floors to the New
Hampshire Department of
Education um we have already taken steps
to consolidate certain uh courses and
programs into the UNH Manchester campus
we're already reaping merger benefits uh
the ones that are easy and
straightforward to reap but we have a
lot of work to do this is going to
consume the better part of the spring
semester uh but I'm very confident that
we're on a good track the cooperation
between the the the uh the communities
in both institutions is very very strong
and uh so far I I'm very encouraged by
what I
see thank you very much uh are there
questions for the dean or for the
administrative
officer representative Porter
either way okay I just have a real
simple question you were talking about
keeping the name etc for the alumni and
I'm wondering upon
graduation what what will it actually
say will it have both colleges on I mean
will have the college and the University
or how does that work the bill um
provides that until July this is where
the work gets very complicated because
they accreditation we have notified the
um the accreditation body but until July
of
2023 degrees would say granted State
College assuming this is approved well
by the legislature and by the
accreditors after July 1st of 2023 the
degree would say the University of New
Hampshire and you can think of that
similarly to the University of New
Hampshire has a college of Health and
Human Services and a colle of
engineering and all the diplomas say the
University of New Hampshire and the same
will hold to for Granite State College
thank you very much repres sentive
Porter thank you Mr chair and that sort
of answers my question too I was going
to ask the same sort of thing it's been
many years since I was at the University
of Massachusetts and amville when I was
there we had many colleges College of
Arts and Science College of Education
Etc um so the grand State College will
be like those colleges
as a under the university umbrella
correct no can I ask one more question
go ahead okay Kean and Plymouth do they
also have colleges underneath them as a
university now or is the definition of
university changed a bit keen and
Plymouth are both both undergone
reorganization over the last probably
three years um I do not believe pouth
and K have separate colleges the
university they I know at Plymouth their
programs are structured very differently
they have clusters of programs and um
Keen I believe has also very much um
restructured so there aren't as
many there aren't a number of colleges
in to AG my old understanding was a
university had many colleges underneath
it or a college was just separate of
itself but now many colleges have become
universities so that must have changed
am
I so today uh the University of New
Hampshire at Manchester for example yeah
is one of seven colleges within UNH
there are five on the Durham campus
there's UNH Manchester and the school of
law is is the seventh College um we are
thinking hard about what the right um
use is of the Granite State College name
in future marketing efforts one of the
uh goals that we have in this
it's not just a matter of cost savings
although it is it is also a matter of
taking steps to try and grow the market
for online learning here in New
Hampshire and hopefully broadly uh and
we do believe that uh UNH um has a
significantly stronger brand um both in
the state and regionally and so we're
thinking hard about the future use of
the granite state name it will be a a
division vision of
unh um but we are working to figure out
what the continued use of Granite State
as a external brand should be given our
ambition to to be a bigger player in the
online uh student learning Market
followup just realized I have one more
question thank you Mr chair so how will
it work then if I'm a student and I'm
interested in um the courses that are
under the College of the grand the state
college will I be applying to the
University of manchest University of New
Hampshire at Manchester or will I be
applying to Grant State College you will
be applying to
UNH so today if you are a student at UNH
Manchester you apply to UNH and you make
an indication as to whether you are
interested in the main campus in Durham
the M the campus in Manchester or have a
equal interest in both and so we will
have a a provision like that but Our
intention is to put U UNH front and
center but maintain all of the same
admissions processes for those students
who prefer to attend UNH in an entirely
online
mode and and so will if I have a twin
sister who wants to apply as well and
wants to take the same course kinds of
course but not at graned state College
rather at
University will she be charged more for
that course if she would prefer a more
residential experience such as the one
you get uh and residential experiences
bring with them greater costs which then
result in Greater tuition because
Granite State is an entirely online
school we don't have those same
operating costs and that supports a much
lower tuition rate that explains it
thank you so much for that EXP
thank you rep representative Woodcock
thank you Mr chairman uh I have two if I
may the first one Mr you mentioned um
initially you said that you're going to
maintain uh the Open Access price point
and when you get back to it the second
time you said you're going to maintain
the Open Access and the price point so
my my question is uh as we move down to
the
2023 uh timetable uh and assuming this
merges rolled into the university system
is the admission Open emmission Access
still going to apply at that point in
time yes okay thank you and I have one
more if I may Mr thank you for and I
could clarify just the motive for that
because I think that's
important the a significant number of
Granite State students are what we call
degree completers right they have a
range of academic experiences at a
number of schools and uh they've proven
themselves as good students having
earned credits at a range of
Institutions at their stage in life the
average age is 33 your SAT scores don't
matter that much your high school GPA
doesn't really matter that much it's
what you've done you know since then
that matters and so online schools tend
to be what we call open admission
because the standards that you would
apply to an incoming 18yearold really
don't apply to this type of learner
and so uh that's why we you know most
online schools are considered open
admission thank thank you you have one
followup yes sir go ahead thank you Mr
chairman just general followup uh at the
20 from now until 2023 and after the
2023 merger uh datee uh is it what is
the intention for the leadership of
Grant State that's currently in in
sitting yeah so
um at the time of of the announcement uh
Chancellor Rubenstein of course left for
the community college system uh the
other significant uh leadership position
was Scott Stanley in the role of provost
um that position has been eliminated and
Scott has actually joined UNH to lead
the University's overall online
infrastructure platform given his
significant experience at Granite State
it made sense to try and take those
learning that Scott had um and apply
that to UNH more broadly as well as
ultimately to the university
system um and so uh at this point there
are two or three other leadership
positions that are continuing to operate
Granite State College but we will have
ultimately a new organization that
results from the merger planning uh that
I fully anticipate will include those
current leaders but perhaps in different
roles thank you thank you Mr chair thank
you representative
mofin yes thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question thank you for
being here uh my understanding of
mergers generally has to do with the
intent or the goal of of streamlining
and and increasing efficiencies and and
removing duplication and that type of
thing and you earlier said that you
don't anticipate any uh staff reductions
or layoffs um but in response to an
earlier question about admissions uh you
explained that the admissions
applications would now go to UNH so the
the question I maybe others have is uh
is there redundancy in admissions or in
burer office or
regist uh and trying to understand why
this merger would not result in any uh
more efficient use of
personnel thanks for the question
representative moett um to be clear um
it likely will result in a reduction of
personnel what I said is why don't
believe we don't believe there are going
to be
layoffs because we already have lots of
vacant positions and rather than fill
those positions we're reexamining all
the vacan I I'll give you an example the
president of granted State
College president Dean has been named by
the board to be the president of granted
State
College
you assume if this uh goes forward and
the accreditation works the president of
Grant State College will be the
president of
unh um on the topic of bursars and
admissions those conversation some of
those conversations are happening across
the university system where can we
leverage scale um so we do believe it's
going to result in cost savings and and
staff reductions but
nutrition and
rethinking various
jobs okay thank you in a quick followup
sure uh Sports um so folks who apply to
the GSC component um who are full-time
students would they be eligible to
participate on any UNH athletic
teams um so I am not a expert in
NCAA um eligibility uh uh considerations
but I do believe that if students are a
uh student enrolled at the University of
New Hampshire and meet the eligibility
requirements of other un students uh
they would likely be be
eligible but they have to meet those
eligibility requirements as un students
um it's it's important to note that um
the vast majority of GSC students
actually attend part-time uh not
full-time by our typical
definitions um and they take a much
longer time to complete their degrees
those are things we'd like to obviously
always accelerate but the reality is
most students are parents working
professionals taking their classes
part-time and so Athletics is not a big
priority for them but I could imagine
that there might be some limited cases
where That Could That Could Happen sure
thank you thank you are there further
questions represent LE us and then
represent Hopson yeah so if a student is
um Granite State and yeah they're their
expenses I mean their costs are reduced
because it's online Etc if they then
decide that they want to take a
particular class at UNH would would
those classes that they take at UNH
proper that would be in person would
those then cost the same as the UN at as
the other students taking those inperson
classes is that the way it's it's a
great question so first of all we
imagine that that will be the exception
not the rule that in those cases where a
student might want to take a
face-to-face class at UNH Manchester
because it fits their interests and
their needs uh that would be offered at
the granite state
at the granite state rate wow such a
deal yeah representa
Hobson but but the same is true that if
you're a UNH and we think this is
actually much more likely if you're a
UNH Manchester student and you want to
take happen to want to take an online
course and say uh the liberal arts and
it works better for your schedule to
take that online you would continue to
pay the UNH rate so we think would even
out thank you for taking my question Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
questions uh and for being here today um
my question is is involving the fiscal
note um the cost seems to be uh ex
indeterminable so I was wondering if you
could tell me what types of costs you're
looking at and
considering the um we do believe there's
going to uh be a an upfront investment
necessary um that the university and the
university system will absorb the the
investment could be for in all
likelihood would be for technology so
for example right now granted State
College and the University of Manchester
uh the University of New Hampshire um
are on two different student Information
Systems so we need to make an investment
to make sure that those um
systems can talk to one another um the
so primarily in the way of of technology
I think the generally when we do a
fiscal note we're asked to determine
what the impact will be on the state we
don't believe there will be any impact
on the state's budget other costs that
we may the other thing I would say when
we did this fiscal
note uh they
absolutely are in in some in some ways
continue to be indeterminable because
we're still in a planning
stage um there was there another bucket
that we had talked about that we might
need to make an investment to to move
this forward yeah I would say it falls
into two categories one is the migration
of information systems and that is by
far the largest single cost that we
expect is the because in some cases
granite state uses completely different
Information Systems in other cases it
uses a separate instance of that system
and therefore then the databases need to
be merged that can be complex and
expensive work and so that is that is a
big part of the transition costs the
other one is uh the launch of marketing
efforts to basically let students know
that things have
changed and and reinforce that univers
Branton state is now part of the
University of New Hampshire so we
imagine a marketing campaign that will
make that clear again we not only want
to preserve the student markets that we
have we want to use this merger to
propel greater growth and so we think it
is going to be money well spent to
invest in a marketing campaign that
communicates what we're doing to the
public thank you very
much are there further questions of per
me represent Nelson thank you for taking
this
question will the UNH professors ad
ation look as if a gron state
college class is equal or will it be one
looking down well if you want this we
give a little more higher priority to un
you guys are only from college yeah so
um so both Granite State College and UNH
are fully accredited by the same
accrediting body Nei um and we imagine
that in the post merger environment Nei
will be the common a creditor for all of
you in h including Granite State College
so a four credit course at Granite State
will be as equally regarded as a four
credit course from UNH classic if you'll
allow me that
phrase um and so in terms of degree
completion uh transcripting it will all
be
considered
co-equal thank you very much
representative for
um so with that uh we have a an
opportunity here to take a short break
uh just uh for um a a better
understanding of where we are in this
particular bill um we're trying to get
uh our bills done and out of this
committee as quickly as possible is
there anybody here on a commune that
needs further information or
understanding of this merger with the
community college system excuse me with
the Granite State
College and the um in UNH Manchester UNH
it would be a college just like the
Agricultural and Life Sciences College
is already within
UNH um if there's not any objection to
that we could take a motion to exec this
bill and get moving with it get it out
and um I think that that would be in
support of our public higher education
study committee and also really send the
signal to the trustees that we
appreciate their work and look forward
to more thought in this whole
process represent bow did you have your
hand
up bad signal okay um if there's not I
will entertain a motion to um motion for
this particular bill repres luno would
you like to make a motion I I'd be happy
to either make the motion or second the
motion but uh but I would definitely
move um that we um recommend uh 12 sorry
OTP and um happy to make that motion
thank you would you like to second that
representative cordelli I would thank
you so representative Moffet your first
try so we have a motion on the table
for HB 12 or excuse me 1218 it's a
merger of Granite State College into the
University of New
Hampshire and the motion is
OTP yes the motion is OTP ought to pass
made by representative luno seconded by
representative
cordelli uh on that motion uh may I
speak briefly to the uh yes you may
thank you very much Mr chair um
uh and uh much appreciate uh uh your
introduction to this bill as well as um
as U as um Miss preventers and uh and um
and Mr Dell's uh support and very clear
explanation about the um the um the uh
the challenges and operations that would
go into uh having such a successful
merger um uh just a just a quick
background I've also had the benefit of
uh working um fairly closely with uh
with Dean Dell over the last six years
at UNH Manchester with the engineering
technology programs there and um and uh
I do have tremendous confidence in
Mike's um operational and
administrational um uh ability and
there's just just no question that
you've got the right Personnel in place
to uh to make this a successful um
campaign thank you very much representa
luno and for those in the committee San
luno has had a lot of work with the
community college system and is and the
university system as well so I
appreciate that do you have uh any
discussion represent
cordelli pass okay representa
mord okay on the o OTP motion uh
representative
cordelli
bom repres representative leakas
yes representative Moffet votes yes
representative
Hobson representative Hobson is not
here uh representative
Ford representative sod is not here
representative
Nelson representative lechfield
yes representative
luno
Cornell representative Tanner
yes representative mamea
yes representative Mullen
yes representative woodcart
yes representative
Porter representative
Paul
representative
walls representative lab
yes so I have
170 uh for
OTB is there any objection to putting
this on consent
not seeing any we'll put it on consent
represent luno would you please write
the blur or excuse me committee
report thank you and what we will do
because we have about five minutes I
believe for
the next bill starts so we will take a
short breather thank
you
okay
uh represent luno
is yes that's right yep good good point
I don't think they gave them to me but
that's a good point
uh well we always want to start with the
vi chair and then go and then she
is not
Tak so you go through the Republicans
first well white sh always VES first and
then and then yeah just go through the
GOP side and then the the ranking member
on the other side votes first for them
so after we VI sh course the shair votes
last so Republican ranking member
Democrat well because she Democrat
Republican Democrat Republican so we
can't really go through this particular
list because in that way
because she she really her name should
be down here Democrat
she's a d
but
par
and
think
how's he
feel
are
Mig
do
Kayla
kayy she was an intern with us last last
year year
think
together to generate a conversation
about some very significant issues uh
that have to do with uh access to
education at present there are a number
of um efforts being made in various
quarters the business and education uh
committees uh that are trying to produce
programs they're funding them that get
students either in high school or into
community colleges and possibly into
universities uh to follow or get
preparation for and then follow follow
into the education for a career Sunday's
newspaper uh the Sunday uh Union
Leader had an article about Preparing
People for careers that continue to
advance the economy and their own
personal interest and that's exactly
what the overall intent of this bill is
meant to generate a discussion of it
basically even though it says authorize
the
um community colleges to award degrees
it's to get to the barrier crossings
that we need to address now rather than
when the mission assignments were made
back in when the community colleges were
formed and so this bill is meant to
generate a discussion that was my intent
to broaden the issue of exactly what was
being discussed just a few moments ago
about joining institutions merging
having gone through the merger of the
University of Massachusetts at L myself
being one of the people involved Tristan
and enthusiasm valuate the need let us
figure out the options for media let us
pick the best path that makes sense as
consensus among
stakeholders so in that regard I think
where 1530 has has headed where it's
likely to land is a sensible bill from
the community college systems
perspective thank you thank you very
much uh representative Bowman do you
have a
question thank you Mr chairman and take
the question can you explain the uh
community colleges bsrn system with the
because I believe that is now a
three-year system and then they go to un
so well depending on what what the
legislature does with the last bill that
you were discussing perhaps right now
the RN to BSN program is actually a 3
plus1 partnership with Granite State
college students can complete three
years at the community college system
with the Community College systems lower
tuition rate and then take the fourth
year through Granite State College still
at the community college systems lower
tuition rate I think that's actually an
excellent model because in addition to
addressing the needs for students were
Place bound it also addresses the need
for
affordability thank you further
questions representative
Cornell thank you and thank you for
taking my question has the community
colge system had any discussions with
the university system about how this
would work or if it's a good idea has
any of that kind of discussion going on
well only in in in general terms now the
illustration that's already been offered
about Plymouth state is one that grew
organically White Mountains Community
College recognized they had students
with that interest approach Plymouth
which has a significant presence in the
North country as the most logical
partner and Plymouth agreed to provide a
faculty member to deliver the courses
needed to to allow to complete that
bachelor's degree program so on a caseby
Case basis that would emerge there there
has been ongoing work to try and figure
out how to help students maximize their
enrollment opportunities the community
college system Pathways that allow
students to capitalize on the lower
tuition rate the community college
system for as long as they possibly can
before transitioning to what are
essentially more expensive options with
University system which would require
relocation so on a caseby Case basis
those conversations are all the time but
not necessarily in a systematic way
thank you thank you representative
Woodcock thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you Chancellor for taking my question
I'd like to follow up on represent
Cornell's thinking um in the example you
gave us said the fouth state college
staff or faculty came down to Berlin to
actually do the PSU program that is that
correct just just to get geography
correct they'd have to come come out
okay oh I'm on the other side of the
mountain unless you're in Pittsburgh
you're not coming down okay okay well
okay thank you um now clarifying the
geography my intent however was to see
so it's not that program sounds to me
different than representative Ford's
initial thinking of as I read it as
Unity colleges offering b or BSS this
this was strictly a pum State program
coming down to burlin to satisfy the
Berlin people they had a demographic of
numbers and ROM was so that and that
plan that's different than creating
backlar programs at that level it's just
like a different site change I'm
thinking so is that is that am I
understand that correctly you have that
exact exactly right
repres what I would tell you is that for
us to offer the additional courses
required for a bachelor's degree would
require additional faculty deliver those
steps for accreditation that would add
expense so to the extent that prit
already has that capacity and is able to
make a cost effective delivery of those
courses at our location it accomplishes
for us most of what what I think
represent for's objectives have been
okay but follow up thank you sir um but
in essence so that's really not creating
Balor program the Community College
that's providing opportunity for Balor
programs through the current four col
assist exactly right okay thank you
thank you Mr Chancellor thank you
further questions the
chancellor this is an ageold issue
that's come for before the public higher
education study committee in in in this
body um five or six years ago and I can
remember several Senators that are well
known on that side of the wall who are
very very oppositional to four-year
program starting at the community
college level that's kind of way up here
but now we're looking at all this
inuendo and and different ways of
looking at the getting a a student
through a four-year degree or a two-year
degree and working cooperatively and
collaboratively together uh between
institutions I think it's something that
really is worthy of our study and assess
it and and then come back so that's why
I will uh put together a subcommittee
here um made up of uh probably three and
three or four and four uh folks that
really want to delve into this so thank
you very much Chancellor yes further if
I may representative one one additional
Point among the 50 states New
Hampshire's consistently in the top 10
for adults with bachelor's degrees
already in hand it's a very well
educated state in that regard as we look
at what the workforce needs over the
next 10 or 15 years what we see is a
greater need for uh certificate programs
for Workforce focused programs very
specific areas of specialization which
has been much more Central to our
mission it's part of the reason why
we're we're a little bit at least a
little bit reluctant to be pulled toward
bachelor's degrees when we think there's
so much work that needs to be done at
the front lines and this includes people
who already have bachelor's degrees who
for reasons of of personal circumstances
or or as their lives change make
decisions to move into other areas of
opportunity here in the state so
again we're not averse to these
conversations we think they're helpful
for ensuring the most efficient use of
resources across the state but we also
want to make sure we don't lose track of
a mission that we think in the next 10
or 15 years is going to be very critical
for the needs of this state's Workforce
thank you very much Chancellor we get
that and it kind of Echoes the intent of
s sp44 which came before us last year
and so uh but had some issues uh um not
associated with where we want to get
going here so thank you very much for
your testimony today and is there
anybody else that would like to
speak no show hands thank you very much
we will close this
hearing and the next hearing starts at
um looks like uh
11:30
next uh bill will be HB 1575 starts at
11:30 that's relative to the W waiver of
tuition in the University system so we
will take a short uh break here and come
back thank
you
than
all
here
they
was
B
they
right
I
qual
they
I'll bet
you
heard
are
don't
after
your
e
it's
d
I think I think we all said
good
e
represent representative Roy who is
going to present the bill Welcome to our
committee now you push you got to get
red thank you chairman members of the
committee I'm here today for your
consideration HP
1575 if you recall uh two years ago we
did a great thing and we passed a bill
that allowed for tuition waivers for the
children of 100% disabled
veterans and part of our logic behind
was that the law currently allowed for
veterans who died in service for their
children to go tuition free and we found
that it was rather unfair that if
someone managed to survive and they were
totally and permanently disabled and
still could not afford to put their
children through college that they
should be in effect penalized for having
survived in the meantime a constituent
brought to my attention as much as we
all looked at it and thought we covered
everything if a veteran dies all things
being equal in other words the child is
eligible for all the criteria for the
tuition waiver but if the veteran dies
before they get to College they lose the
benefit and they're not able to go so
what this does is a simple fix all it
says it adds one line to the bill that
as it exists that says that if the
veteran dies prior to the a student
being eligible to go and he dies while
he's a resident of New Hampshire the
child is
eligible and that is really the simple
down and dirty on that bill and with
that I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee
committee
members yes representative
Nelson what is the definition of
disabled I mean I know what IV Vision
but I do know
how you use the
system
um I agree and we we when we originally
passed this bill a year and a half ago
we really delved into that to make sure
it's 100% permanent and disabled uh
permanent disabled service connected
that means that you have gone through uh
numerous exams by the Veterans
Administration and they have determined
that you your disability is 100% And
that there's no chance of you getting
better um and and when you look at VA
math to get to 100% it's very very very
difficult you can lose several Limbs and
still not be 100% disabled so it's a
it's a rigorous process so while I agree
in every system there are people that
abuse it um the VA system is one of the
toughest to uh to be able to do such a
thing further
questions yes
thank you thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for coming to speak to us
today uh I don't expect an exact answer
to this question but I'm G to ask the
question anyhow do you have any sense at
all about the numbers as far as how
many students this would generate into
the tuition waiver program thank you for
the question when we passed the original
bill um we did a lot of research uh
combined with the with the university
and college systems and they determined
that it it it would not be because of
the strict limitations we put on it to
to become eligible for this there would
not be very many and um and I
unfortunately I can't give you a number
off the top of my head but it would not
be be very many um the the criteria were
very strict as far as the U residency
requirement the age they age out at age
26 they're no longer eligible so you
can't have old older people coming back
and getting their doctorates or anything
like that we made it very very strict so
adding this line does all
because um they would have
been eligible anyway it's just that the
sponsor died um so it should have no
impact on the what we already originally
came up with for
numbers representative Mass
Miller thank you representative and
thank you for taking my question um I
was wondering will this include the
community college system as
well yes it's supposed to include
everything that the original Bill
included University and Community
College system it was pointed out to me
um by a u a member of the community
college system um outside that the way
where it's placed in the bill it might
not cover that so an amendment may be
required to make sure it covers
everybody that was eligible on the
original bill and I'll be looking at
that I'd be happy to work with any
member of the committee that wants to
introduce such an amendment um if I may
I was just informed uh with regard to
the previous question they anticipate
between 100 and 125 students per year
are eligible for this and that number as
we disengage from conflicts throughout
the world should
shrink further questions
yes thank you Roy thank you for taking
the question I appreciate your work um
just for my own Clarity I've forgotten
since I
does the student already have to be
previously
enrolled with this or can the the
veteran have passed and then the student
enrolled um the veteran can have passed
and then the student enrolled so long as
the student was
eligible um at the time the veteran
passed in other words the the veteran
was a resident of New Hampshire the
student was everything fits together in
the veteran past they can still go for
example if a student is um you know in
eighth grade gr and their father or
mother passes away they'd still be able
to take admin addes when they get
college aged thank you so much thank you
Mr chairman thanks for question repesent
Tanner uh thank you and thank you for
sponsoring this bill I think this is
really really important um I was
wondering with the number of 100 if that
includes the disabled and not just the
ones that you're uh trying to get in
under this bill under this tuition reg
uh that number represents the total
total that would be 100% permanent Tak
to go to college so 100 between 100
and 25 I don't anticipate this bill
should increase that because it's still
the original pool that we would be
pulling from great thank you further
questions representative
Porter thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Greg um the manner of
death is not a consideration at
all no representative um and the reason
that a lot OFA lately I just want
understood the reason that I didn't get
into the method of death or whether the
death was connected to their service or
not is because they had already passed
the hurdle to have their child be
eligible anyway to tack that on would
almost be a post post humous punishment
so further
questions no further questions seen
thank you very much I thank the
committee for your time thank you
chairman
okay we have Kevin Grady the clerk just
said as you were so he's got that
military spirit in a colonel telling a
lieutenant welcome not thank you thank
you sir very much for the record uh uh
ladies and gentlemen of the committee uh
my name is Kevin Grady uh following a
25- year career in the Air Force I have
uh been a resident of hookit now for the
last 23 years uh and today I'm here not
speaking as myself I'm here speaking on
behalf of the 20 member organizations of
the state veterans advisory committee
and for those of you who are unfamiliar
with what we do we're actually chartered
by state RSI to speak for the veteran
community in New Hampshire and one of
the things that we do each year is we
look at all of the bills that are coming
for Ward to be considered that we think
have veteran impact and then we discuss
those and we take a position on it and
then I come and tell you what our
position is we strongly supported the
original bill on this uh two years ago
and we unanimously also support this
bill too um if if we had a veteran who
passed away on the money that that
veteran was making it would have been
very difficult a permanent and totally
disabled veteran if their sole source of
income was the money from the VA
no child of theirs would be able to
afford to go to school in New Hampshire
I mean that's just the bottom line and
so we thought the original legislation
was good and college would be out of the
question potentially for the children of
that veteran if that veteran would to
pass away either before they went to
school or while they were enrolled in
school so we do strongly support uh this
it was a unanimous decision when we took
the vote last week and subject to your
questions that's all I wanted to tell
you this morning thank you any questions
for Mr
Grady not seeing thank you very much
thank you chairman Mr
chairman represent balero you're
up hello Mr chairman as you know what's
first s make lieutenants and all the way
up the colonels we help them out there
be successful by the way all right but
anyways uh representative alal s for the
rec rocket him County District 5 I uh
support this bill 150% and the reason
why I do is I believe this brings the uh
New
Hampshire uh veteran Community or in
line with the federal government and
when I say in line with the federal
government meaning if you're 100%
disabled veteran there's money there uh
that the student gets that helps offset
for books and other expenses there that
the federal government gives to that
veteran U child so this here would
definitely make a big difference uh on
helping the children of those disabled
veterans that cannot work and it's a
win-win for the State of New Hampshire
on basically not leaving one behind and
taking care of our own and I thank you
and that's all I have thank you very
much representative are there questions
for representative all
zero not seeing hands thank you thank
you anybody else on the
dock that's all the uh Pink oh you have
a
Shannon are you wanting to speak on this
bill oh
welcome good morning my name is Shannon
Reed I represent the community college
system of New Hampshire and as H the
sponsor noted the intent here I believe
was to include the community college
system in the expansion of this waiver
if the committee um opts to do that the
place that that would need to go is RSA
188f colon 15 Roman 1A subp paragraph a
and I can repeat that if needed um and
it would simply be adding the same
language that is in bold in the bill as
introduced to that paragraph and we we
would certainly um be very happy to have
that done so for clarification purposes
F15 colon
151a and then sub paragraph a after that
okay thank you are there questions for
Shannon Reed at the community college
system thank you very
much are there further pink
cards thank you very much with that I
will close this
hearing
uh in terms of those that are here in
the committee right now is there any
thought uh about involving the community
college system within this uh Bill yes I
hear a couple yeses
so so w working with uh representative
Roy if he's still here he's already gone
can we come up with some amending
language to incorporate this RSA that
was just given by Shannon Reed into the
bill and we can bring that up when we
move forward with
it we're going to add in the community
college system with an amendment and
then move it when that's done thank
you 188 F col 15 one sub paragraph a to
be on page 418 and your new education
law is annotated so it's 188
F
colon 15
1 d a d a sub paragraph
a
okay
they will
yeah okay we'll do
that okay we're let's see uh looks like
we're at the point now where the bills
which we had set for the morning are
done we thought the second bill would go
a little longer it didn't so we are done
until
1:00 and I want to bring it to
everybody's attention we are
streaming continue to be streaming even
when we're not acting on a bill the I
understand the audio is shut down but we
are still streaming still have the
visual yeah make sure your mics are off
so eat your sandwich
politely I guess we're done let's take a
break another
break oh yeah and make sure all
yours
e
hello thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee representative Tom lanzer
from
nasua come before you to today to
discuss hb1
1574 relative to prohibiting the
university system and Community College
systems of New Hampshire from charging
out ofate tuition to students voting in
New Hampshire
New Hampshire is unique in that we allow
many students who live here nine plus
months out of the year to vote and claim
their University as their
home while some may agree that this is
an incorrect voting policy every United
State citizen 18 and older has the right
to vote in New
Hampshire what this bill seeks to
accomplish is to prevent the
universities and Community College
systems from charging out state tuition
Should students be allowed to vote
claiming their college system as
residents if students are claiming our
great state is this voting in our
elections potentially working and paying
taxes but still paying AB state tuition
for their
education that is not a just practice to
the members of our
state and thank you Mr chairman and
committee for your
time thank you very much are to uh take
questions I will okay are there any
questions from the
committee looks like you're off the hook
thank you again thank you very much do
we have other pink
cards represent Tim
Horgan
thank you very much Mr chair my name is
represent Timothy Oregon from dord
district 6 which is the towns of Durham
and Madbury and um Durham is not
coincidentally the home of University of
New Hampshire and we're also the next
town over Newton is the home of Great
Bay Community College which is one of
the L major community colleges in the
community college system so I'm uh I'm
opposed to this uh I'm opposed this bill
even though I certainly think um
students should vote um student voting
is a is a good idea colleges when you
develop lifetime habits and voting is a
good habit to get into so I think
students uh should
vote and
um but this bill as written um would
create uh would create Havoc as every
so-called outof State student um which
is sort of a misnomer but anyway every
student who's living in another state
before they came to uh UNH would
probably would be probably tempted to
register to vote rather than um voting
wherever else they might also still have
a uh a residence for the um because this
is a huge at least the way the tuition
is structured right now this is a huge
um discount it's like I think it's
something like an order of $155,000 a
year and that's actually the legality
that's questionable since it's actually
illegal as well as a bad idea to pay
people to vote
you're paying them a huge sum of money
effectively and that's uh so I don't
know if that's going to pass mustard
with Federal uh Federal elections law um
creates as I said it creates Financial
chaos for the University because uh
they'll have a hard time budgeting it
also means
um we do have a few other Provisions
about uh tuition but basically we've
we've with except for a few uh
Provisions about um allowing they
allowing like uh establishing
scholarship sh for for veterans and
first responder children of veterans and
First Responders and a few other things
we haven't really delved this much into
the mechanics out of state universities
and community colleges set their tuition
and obviously they have to set tuition
high enough to uh you know meet meet
their budgets so what they're probably
what they probably do is uh instead of
charging so-called instate students you
know half the tuition they'll probably
just you know have to charge them the
same tuition as uh so-called out ofate
students and that's not I don't think
there's anybody in the room who thinks
that's a good
policy and um funny to get back I said
that the term out of State student
student is a misnomer um students
regardless of where they lived you know
before they came to UNH or any other
community college or before they
attended a community college um they are
residents of the community where they
are 9 months out of the year or many
cases 12 months out of the year so they
are so all those students in the dorms
and the off-campus housing unage they
are residents of Durham they're counted
as such in the
census you know they're uh so really
legally there's not much distinction
between out of state and instate um
students really is any definition you
can draw that uh a would make sense and
B also wouldn't interfere with uh
certain Supreme Court decisions such as
the I believe it's a Sims decision which
was reached back in 1979 the same year I
graduated from college um so
and what the instate versus out ofate
tuition uh thing is basically it's based
on where your family and you know the
student themselves so they usually young
people they don't pay much taxes but
where the families paying taxes
before the student enrolled the UN so
it's based on uh your sort of
essentially that's one of the things
you've been paying for with your taxes
if you're families living in state is uh
you know the possibility you might want
to go to UNH on the instate tuition so
they
it's based on where they've been living
and paying taxes beforehand and um
finally one other point is this is
discriminatory against students who
uh can't
vote say if they're foreign Nationals um
say if they're under the age of 18 which
um you know many many freshmen are under
the age of 18 or if they if they belong
to a uh religion which forbids voting
and actually I think one of the sponsors
was brought up in a religion that
actually forbids its members from voting
although he he left the church obviously
because he's serving the legislature so
or also even just people who don't want
to vote because they don't really want
you know maybe they have the bumper
sticker on their car don't vote it only
encourages them so there's like a large
number of people so you know so
discriminates against those students who
either can't vote or choose for whatever
reason not to vote so this is a this
bill has come up every year or two and
it's always uh been ited and I hope
you'll uh make the same recommendation
this
time thank you very much representative
are there any questions for
representative
Horgan represent M thank you m shair
thank you represent for taking my
question um knowing that you're a
veteran legislator from a college town
yeah um do you know of any other state
where an out of state out of State
student paying out of state tuition can
same day register in an election and
have that vote count that same day well
that'll probably be a more question for
uh someone from the Secretary of State's
office there are um I believe certainly
every other state treats uh so-called uh
out of state students on the same
footing as uh instate students I myself
went to two universities out of state
and I um voted um I voted uh I voted uh
in New York City for a while at when I
was attending Columbia University and
then in Los Angeles when I was attending
University of Southern California and u
c those are private institutions whole
instate versus out of state tuition
thing doesn't kick in you know they have
the same tuition rate for everybody
they're not State institutions but U
I um
I I don't know the uh we are same day
voter registration is um you know not
every state has it um but
I don't see any reason why somebody who
moved to the state because they they're
attending
school um deserves to have fewer rights
than somebody who moves there for
whatever other reason I just also
clarifies about veterans a lot I'm a
veteran as in I've been through a lot of
legislative terms I myself um am not a
veteran of military service not the
closest I can come to was having been a
uh civilian employee of the Army Corps
of Engineers in Hanover which is a
college town but that college too is
also a private one
so okay that's thank you I met
experienced legislator yes oh well
that's
fine are there further questions
represent LE
us yeah I'm trying to figure out
your
obje in that it would seem you want to
encourage students to V would this not
encourage students
vot and um and the other half of that is
cannot students
vote
um absentee ballot from the wherever it
was that came from even in college yes
well I'm um I'm glad to see that the
party that has a majority caucus in this
body still supports absentee voting they
weren't so enthusiastic about it last
year when record number of absentee
votes cast um they may um the student
they may be more interested in the uh
what's going on in New Hampshire than in
their old home state they also they're
not always necessarily always eligible
to vote in some other state um and then
absentee absentee voting is uh it's not
quite as easy it's I mean it's it's not
extremely difficult but it's uh not not
as trivial as uh you know some make it
out to be and it's uh frankly um
there seems to be at least some some
people here here in the New Hampshire
house and other legislative bodies who
want to make it more difficult so they
not
um so it should be up to the they they
should have the same rights as anybody
else who has multiple residents you know
there's lots of you know it's being a
student is no different say being
somebody who spends a lot of months at a
vacation home in Florida or whatever so
they they have the same legal rights as
anybody else so they um and as for
encouraging students to vote that's fine
but a 15,000 a year payment you know it
could be $60,000 or more over the course
of a degree program that's it's illegal
and that's also grossly excessive you
know so it's it's people should people
should vote because they they want to
vote not because somebody's paying
them thank you very much further
questions not see thank you very
much uh representative Cody
blanger thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee appreciate you hearing
this uh testimony today appreciate
everybody behind me being here as
well this bill doesn't make it more
difficult for college students it
encourages them to attend University
here in the state of New Hampshire they
also get discount it's not paying for
students to vote that is that's absurd
we're not going to do that this bill
seeks to offer fairness to University
students because if they're going to
claim domicile in state of New Hampshire
and they're going to vote in our
elections why don't they get in state
tuition that's the question that we're
talking about okay so when I went to the
University of New Hampshire and I was a
social work major don't get me started
on how I was treated as a republican
there I voted in my domicile which was
eping and Brentwood New Hampshire okay
two different times when I voted there
by the way I didn't vote in the same
year two different polling locations
just want to make that very
clear um when I went to the University
of New Hampshire part of my application
process was that I had to say that I was
a resident of New Hampshire and I don't
remember the period of time I think it
was either 12 months or or more than
that but if uh
if a student is voting in New Hampshire
they have a right to instate tuition
they're considering themselves a
resident they are domiciled here and
that's what this bill seeks to
do um from campuses that seek to offer
fairness to all
students doesn't seem pretty fair that
they're going to let them vote help them
vote help them register to vote but then
also charge them out of state to it you
doesn't really seem fair to me uh with
that uh I'd be happy to take any
questions are there questions for the
representative representa I have one
question um looking at this from a
fiscal
perspective um if all students that
we're talking about opt become instate
tuition
students we're looking at a loss of
Revenue of over $139 million potentially
how will the state or how will the
university
system make that up do you have any idea
how to do that perhaps they should cut
administrative staff with a topheavy
Administration thank
you further
questions thank you very much
representative thank
you uh the next person we have on the
docket is Shannon Reed community college
system New
Hampshire good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Shannon Reed I'm
here on behalf of the community college
system of New Hampshire thank you for
the opportunity to testify
today um first I'd like to say that only
about 6% of students at the community
colleges are out of state tuition payers
um in a given year between 93 and 96% of
our students are New Hampshire residents
we don't typically weigh in on bills
that deal with voting and domicile
because there's really no impact um to
our our students or our institution
that's not so much the case with with
this bill necessarily but that impact is
really only on the six% that don't pay
in state tuition for purposes um of Our
Testimony we assume that we would
determine um residency and voting by
basically matching a student database
against the New Hampshire voter database
that's maintained by the New Hampshire
Secretary of State and that somehow we
could automate that process to
streamline it and and minimize
costs
um that said though um running those
checks to cross check our student
database against the voter database
would have to take place very frequently
throughout the year as new cohorts of
students register and pay tuition um um
we would ccsnh has rolling admission
registration and payment timetables and
multiple times throughout the year when
courses begin and students May enroll so
there would be a a significant amount of
work associated with literally
every um maybe monthly or every few
weeks even running this check to see
when our students have enrolled and
registered and paid whether they were in
fact registered to vote in New Hampshire
or not but second would be the potential
effect on tuition Revenue instate
tuition is significantly lower than out
of state tuition at the community
colleges we would experience some
decrease in Revenue that could result
from the mandate to reclassify residency
for tuition purposes for any student who
registers to vote in New Hampshire based
on the Secretary of State's guidelines
for establishing domicile in the
state um the we can't really calculate
the decrease because we can't predict
how many students would would make this
change if if zero% of our ad of State
students um registered to vote in New
Hampshire and there thereby had to be
reclassified then the impact would be
zero if 100% of them did the impact on
our colleges would be just over a
million dollars a
year um the legislation may also require
a statutory change authorizing the
community colleges to have access to the
Statewide voter database and we would we
would look for guidance from the
Secretary of State's office on how that
would work and what if any costs would
be
incurred um in closing I'd urge the
committee to consider consider carefully
whether it wants to create an incentive
for non- New Hampshire students to
register to vote in New Hampshire in
order to be eligible for instate tuition
rates as as was stated before um a
student who otherwise might not desire
to vote in New Hampshire could simply
register to do so in order to get
instate tuition rights as opposed to the
out of state costs which are more than
double instate costs so that is my
testimony I I will submit it in writing
and happy to take any questions thank
you very much represent leas
yes when I went to Michigan State um the
college didn't decide who got which once
you were enrolled if you were a student
and you wanted to be in state you
applied and so you wouldn't have to do
any of that checking paperwork change
laws anything it would be on the head of
the student to apply to for the
change thank you representative I
appreciate the comment I think that we
would feel an obligation to verif verify
as we do currently for instate tuition
rates we do verify when a student
indicates that they are inate or
not are there further questions for
Shannon Reed yes representative wood
thank you chairman
L thank you for thinking a question um
you indicated that about 6% the Comm
call
system out of you Happ to know your
professional affiliation what that
number may be system I don't know but
I'm sure that someone behind me who will
testify subsequently could tell you that
okay and I guess the second question um
representative spoke before you
indicated he thought1 139 million cost
could be saved by cutting the
administrative staff do you think that
would do
it thank you for that question
representative um I I no I don't think
so thank you thank you Mr chairman are
there further questions of the community
college
system not seeing thank you very
much
next okay we welcome Tom Cronin
University system New
Hampshire good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee Tom Cronin
director of government relations for the
University system I do have written
testimony that's uh being distributed
now I think I'll keep my comments brief
however um really it's two points um
currently our Board of Trustees sets uh
your ability to uh obtain instate
tuition based really on two main factors
one uh have you physically resided in
the state of New Hampshire for 12 months
or more and two are you doing so for
some reason other than
education okay so you can't really that
second one is key you can't therefore be
a freshman uh spends a year here and all
of a sudden then gets inate tuition
sophomore through senior year right
those are the two key uh pieces of
information we use right now I think as
representative Oran said there are other
waivers particularly related to the
military Etc that change that in very
discreet cases uh as representative llad
said should this legislation pass it
would be approximately $140 million a
year in Lost Revenue to the university
system to representative woodcock's uh
question we are across the system about
5050 in state and out UNH is maybe a
little bit more out of state than in
state while keen and Plymouth are a
little bit more in State versus out and
then graned State largely is in state um
those numbers do fluctuate for example
some of our most recent uh admissions
data at the University of New Hampshire
we're seeing an uptaken inate applicant
so they do hover around but 5050 is
approximately a fair uh approximation so
I think we would essentially for purpose
of the fiscal note and otherwise assume
that should this legislation pass any
nonresident student would immediately
register to vote for a $15,000 a year
plus discount on their education uh
which given those numbers would be uh
tremendously tremendously difficult
Revenue situation for the University um
again as representative Oregon mentioned
this bill is I think nearly identical to
uh what was House Bill 429 last year
that was referred to the election law
committee was it out of that committee
20 to nothing but was one of the series
of bills that did not get acted on on
the floor uh at crossover last year so
uh we would encourage you to follow that
lead um of election law and itl this one
as well and I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you very much Mr crin
are there questions for the University
system I I have one um for years we have
tried within the university system to
keep our ratio between out ofate and
instate tuition students at close to a
5050 sometimes it's not right there and
it's very different than that we see
over at UVM where we see 80% out of
state and 20% inst State my concern is
if we go ahead and move in this
direction will we then be providing and
Counting these students which come in
for example from
Montana stay here for four years and
then exit back to
Missoula um are we then going to be
sliding our instate and cutting off the
number of kids which really have lived
here and graduated from high school here
and our in state students that's a great
Point representative I mean certainly it
would be I think a attractor to out
ofate students I mean this would be a
significantly lower uh rate than they'd
pay to attend some other out ofate
school perhaps than their local school
um so certainly it would be something to
attract students from across the country
I do think as you know as a a member of
the board um we do try and prioritize if
you have two equal students a New
Hampshire resident and a non-resident we
are unfortunately at a position where we
are full up in all of our classes but in
that case we would always prioritize a
New Hampshire resident for uh limited
spots um so I think it's likely you
would see an increase in enrollment but
uh not at a rate that we need to
continue to sustain operations thank
you representa Tanner then
representative
wood I may be taking representative
Woodcock steam here but I'd like to ask
if you think you could make up that
money those millions of dollars by doing
administrative efficiency I do
not Woodcock was that your question well
it was one thank you okay you got one
may have one more representative yes
thank you Mr con thank you for
testifying I appreciate the information
um as far as UNH in the bigger picture
uh with instate tuition um how how do we
stand in terms of the other primary
major uh State institutions across the
F50 you have a b we are on that yeah so
I think as as as is well documented New
Hampshire is one of the more expensive
um some years the most expensive public
hire education system in the country um
representative lad referenced Vermont uh
usually we are buying back and forth
with Vermont for that unfortunate
distinction uh as folks in this
committee know uh us and Vermont also
share a distinction of being one of the
lowest funded public education systems
in the country um so right now we are
among the more expens thank you thank
you represent chairman l further
questions yes representative luno thank
you very much Mr chair and thanks very
much Mr Cronin for being here this
afternoon and this morning as well um
just for context obviously the fiscal
note talks about approximately $140
million loss if um if current out of
state students um uh convert over to um
to instate tuition um could you put that
number say in the context of what the um
um University of New Hampshire provides
students for financial
aid I cannot unfortunately I I will get
back to you on that but one of the uh
the concerns we would have in the event
there was a piece of legislation like
this that became law would be we would
largely need to cut financial aid
significantly that is more likely how we
would address Revenue shortfalls we
would increase rates for everybody
because essentially everybody would be
paying the same rate we would have to
reduce financial aid availability right
so followup Mr chair yes so um
and and it was a little bit of an unfair
question do you have the answer because
you don't have it right in front of you
but yeah so this is sort of like a would
you believe so I'm I'm actually looking
at the 20 um 2029 I'm sorry 2019 uh
comprehensive annual financial report
the caffer and um I'm sure I've got the
2021 on here but the 2019 came up one
first so would you believe that student
financial aid for the University system
of New Hampshire is um is $196 million
uh I certainly would believe that and I
think if you looked at 21 uh you would
have seen that number continue to
increase that has been a primary focus
of the board and of Campus leadership is
to continue to increase financial aid
offering really for both instate and out
of state students um so I'm confident if
you looked at that most recent report
the number would actually be a tick High
great thank you very
much thank you further
questions thank you very much Tom thank
you any more cards is there anybody else
in the public here that would like to
testify on this
bill not seeing any we're closing this
hearing
okay
13 right
onu okay we're going to go into the next
hearing which is HB
1648 requ requiring public colleges and
universities to implement peer support
groups and develop policies for students
with mental health
conditions do we have any cards on that
yes okay who's the first one dispor
hope
welcome rip and La Branch you've got
the thank you chairman and good
afternoon uh House Education committee
uh my name is representative La Branch I
represent amher New Hampshire uh I will
explain why I'm introducing this bill
beforehand before introducing the bill
as the youngest uh representative in New
Hampshire history
this bill is tremendously important to
me as many of us know mental health is
an ofer often overlooked part of
healthare and our Health Care system the
problem is especially uh pressing when
it comes to young adults with most
mental health conditions appearing
before age
25 this issue is compounded by the
stress of young adulthood transitioning
from high school to full adult
Independence being a hard transition for
many I know that myself having just
turned 20 being a representative a
part-time college student working
part-time it can be a struggle to fit
everything into your
schedule I will not hide it from the
committee but I myself have struggled
with
depression I've been without a therapist
since June of 2021 and have been
searching for one since then and have
yet to find one it is hard to find a
therapist that deals with young adults
and truly understands us as young adults
colleges and universities are the
perfect place to bridge the gap between
students with mental health needs and
finding the help and services that they
need sorry I think I'm G to take off my
mask real
quick now how does this bill address
that this bill seeks to identify more
students with mental health needs and
connect them with access and services
increase mental health services offered
by colleges increase access to
off-campus Mental Health Services and
provide training to raas advisers and
other staff and identifying the signs of
mental health crises this is a low cost
and simple modification that will help
many students find the help that they
need and that they
deserve now let me close off my remarks
with this my best friend who is a little
bit younger than me has suffered with
mental health issues such as thoughts of
suicide when he reached out for help he
was sent to the hospital where he spent
eight days waiting for Pediatric bed to
open up eight days of hearing screaming
being surrounded by by dep and traumatic
events spending 8 days in an emergency
room did not help my friend if anything
it re-traumatized them and made
everything worse that is why this bill
is so important we need to help bridge
the gap between those who need help and
the help that they need I hate to say
this but this is the lowest cost
solution to this issue besides simply
ignoring it and with that I ask that you
pass this bill with ought to pass and I
am happy to answer any questions
although some might be answered by the
speakers behind me
uh and I also have a statement from
another member that could not be here
today thank you very much are you going
to I can wait to read the statement and
answer question read that one following
um the questions your questions to you
um are there any questions for the
speaker right now for the
representative yes representative
om thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking the question
all through life you might say there are
peer groups set up for all kinds of
diseases voluntary peer groups so why
can't that same thing be done in
different colleges and universities
people can get together and start peer
groups for pretty much anything which
has been done so why can't you do it
without the state involved uh as a
patient who had colon cancer at a young
age uh I have been part of peer groups
uh as you mentioned um this is basically
making it so that there is a
professional in the room as mental
health is such a complex topic and um we
don't want uh unpr uh people who are not
trained in dealing with mental health
issues being the ones that you go for
professional help because uh people
deserve uh help in uh a professional
manner
thank
you thank you my question thank you my
question it's a simple one um this uh
Bill if pass would apply to all colleges
in the New Hampshire correct uh it would
apply to all uh State uh colleges and
universities so the community college
system and the UN system all
public one more thank you um are you
aware of any I guess I'm trying to sign
besides the acknowledgement that there
is not sufficient Services across that
um are you aware of any programs
currently in place in our college system
that is trying to reach out and help uh
in one way or
another or is this just a void you're
trying to
fill I believe some
colleges um I believe this is more of an
effort to standardize this uh because
every college and university is
different in how they reach out to their
students uh with mental health issues
um and as somebody who has been looking
for a therapist and goes to the
community college system it has been
hard to find
help thank you thank you represent W
you're welcome are there further
questions yes represent
lakus I have two questions one if you're
having trouble finding a therapist
because there's a
shortage um how are the universities
going to therapists willing to partner
with
them so in this legislation it uh states
that the college will uh form agreements
with uh providers in the area um this
will be professionals who are trained to
deal with young adults uh I believe that
is one of the biggest pressing concerns
I understand there is a shortage but um
even just finding someone who uh deals
with young adults is difficult um and
this would standardize the process of
finding somebody that can at least treat
young adults and not just a generalized
therapist and going through your
insurance and your primary care doctor
and trying to find a care
provider thank you and can I ask a SLE
question yes how how will you um
maintain privacy for those who need
help this is a a obviously you can
identify the signs it does not mean
somebody need needs to get help because
it's always up to the individual to get
help this is more if you have an issue
uh a mental health issue and you would
like to find help that you can find help
this is not mandating that uh people are
I I saw an email from somebody
testifying uh saying that it would uh
you would identify individuals and send
them to help that is not what this bill
does this is simply giving access to the
the mental health that people need thank
you you're welcome are there further
questions oh yes represent Nelson thank
you for taking my question
chairman would you expect all people to
be together with this disability or
would you want each group dealing with
specific subjects that they need to talk
with LA support groups support groups um
I believe that will be a a colleg to col
basis depending on how many students and
how many students want to participate in
these programs uh My Hope Is that many
students who do need help participate in
these programs and they can always form
groups that are specialized in
depression and anxiety but uh at least
having a general mental health uh group
would be
helpful yes thank you how would elig
eligibility be
determined is it just to stop in
actually I don't feel good to I want to
talk to everybody or is it you have to
have a
diagnosis um
many mental health issues go
undiagnosed like we had mentioned before
there are issues of access to
professionals and getting a professional
diagnosis um I I I would assume that it
would be a voluntary uh you don't need a
diagnosis to go to these help groups
just like Alcoholics Anonymous or other
uh illnesses that you go to a support
group it would be just like that so it's
a self-identified knot you don't need to
walk in there with the doctor's note is
what I'm saying
yes represent M thank you Mr chair and
thank you for your testimony for being
here do you foresee any possible privacy
issues in terms of uh people having to
disclose uh health condition to
participate or to be eligible
for uh some involvement in this program
uh privacy issues have you're given that
any any consideration uh the peer
support group as I had mentioned earlier
is a voluntary you go there because you
want help and you acknowledge that you
will be talking about your mental
illness with other individuals in that
group but everything else is uh purely
voluntary and you will only be uh
disclosing that with a mental health
professional and all the Hippa rules
apply to that follow
up so I I'm I'm wondering about
attending the peer support group would
there be uh Records taken minutes uh
attendance
attendees uh
the fact that someone may or may not
have something diagnosed if they show up
at one of these uh sessions um and
they're on a list of attendees or people
know that they attended I'm wondering if
there's possible stigmatization that
could flow from that you tracking my my
concern uh yes and I would say that um a
lot of the public knows about Alcoholics
Anonymous groups um it's it's Anonymous
uh and that's the same idea here there's
no records taken and there's no uh
there's no paper trail is what I'm
trying to say and it's just um we we
trust each other uh if you go to that
group uh when everything stays in the
Alcoholics Anonymous session it's the
it's the same thing here thank
you further questions yes
representative thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative for taking my
question my question is does your bill
the use of tele medicine T Health
Medicine yes um and I will actually
start that with a a personal note um
before um before the pandemic I had to
see my mental health professional in
Boston driving an hour away since uh
cental Health was not an option and it
still is not an option I I was lucky
enough that during the pandemic they
allowed uh tele medicine so I could see
that uh mental health professional but
yes this bill does include tele Health U
tele medicine I should say U so that
everybody can access uh a mental health
professional are there any other
questions from the
committee yes representer
Nelson just have a con a crazy concern
if you have six students that are
involved in this which is a good idea
how is it paid for are insurance
companies paying six different insurance
companies paying the same Professor or
different professors or uh people for
counseling uh I believe peer support
groups uh like I had mentioned earlier
like Alcoholics Anonymous or other
support groups um there's no cost to
actually attending the
session yes represent
Mullen thank you chairman lad uh and
welcome
representative um my question has to do
with the arrangements between local
resources and the college
campus um I I'm assuming that there
would in fact be a bill associated with
Contracting with people in the local
community um and there are some costs
estimated in here uh to the university
system uh that are around a a million
two basically in total um do you have
any sense of uh sort of piggybacking on
representative Nelson's question um
would would those services that are
contracted be paid for by the University
or would an individual student's medical
health insurance cover the cost
of involving
professionals as the fiscal note uh
States it would be the college system
but I believe that that is for finding
initial help and then after that you
have found your therapist I believe uh
if you do have insurance or insurance
will kick in at that
point at least that's my understanding
further questions not seeing any hands
now you also said you had a statement
from another individual yep uh I have a
how long is that a page and a half it
seems rather than reading the whole
thing can you just submit that to the
Clerk and clerk can put that into the
record I can thank you thank
you okay are these the same group
here yes representative Porter you have
a
question I I how can
you we can copy made of that and
distribute to everybody okay make it
simple okay the next person to speak is
representative Megan
Murray good afternoon thank you
chairman my name is Megan Murray I
represent the town of Amherst New
Hampshire uh I did submit uh for the
record of an electronic copy of my
testimony so I'm not going to believe
her the point I would like to note
however that to touch on some of the
things that the spor mentioned um my
intent is to see access to resources and
opportunities continue to be presented
for folks with mental
illness as we know um individuals
seeking treatment or care or may who who
may just be starting out on that Journey
may not know where to go at all for help
and a peer support is one of those first
steps that somebody May seek to take in
in saying that I would also like to note
that um as college students are
transitioning into the workforce is
crucial that they understand what
support they have for themselves going
into a community oftentimes folks with
mental health conditions require
appointments that are weekly or
bi-weekly monthly in nature um and often
times that requires them to schedule
them around their work environment so
having those opportunities to start that
trajectory towards Wellness in the
College Community I find um to be
extremely helpful and as we know um
there's a there's a lack of short
shortage of providers like you all have
noted but I think um having heard from
some young individuals out in the
community and their testimony that what
they are asking for is for individuals
who have been through such similar
situation to help at least in guiding
the conversation of where to begin for
where to go next just like we had
mentioned um with whether it's Narcotics
Anonymous or Alcoholics Anonymous that
is really the intent of connecting folks
in the University system to resources so
I thank you thank you very much are
there any questions for the
representative thank you very much for
your testimony thank you
it
next speaker is Shannon Reed community
college system New
Hampshire thank you Mr chairman for the
record my name is Shannon Reed I'm here
on behalf of the community college
system of New
Hampshire ccsnh values the intent of
this bill but with respect we cannot
support it as written we we do
appreciate the attention that is being
paid to the mental health of college age
students we followed higher education
news about mental health issues
including um students on uh I'm sorry
including suicides on campuses um
including recently in the New England
region at colleges like WPI Dartmouth
and nor Eastern these are tragic and
heartbreaking isolation caused by the
pandemic has certainly played a role in
this recent Boston Globe coverage on the
suicides at WP pi and Dartmouth pointed
to students isolated in dorm rooms
taking classes remotely eating their
meals alone in dorms with very limited
extracurricular or social activities and
having very little interaction with
their peers across campus this is
certainly exacerbated mental health
challenges already faced by many in this
age group the mental health of our
students is a focus of our work we
strive to put in place supports and
linkages that are helpful compassionate
accessible and effective given the
nature of the population that we serve
and the kind of Campus environments that
we have in the last few years we have
created new opportunities for students
to access mental health supports such as
free access to tella health for mental
health check-ins during high stress
times of year links and referrals to
area mental health agencies and
maintaining life supports like food
pantries as we review hb1
1648 we would caution the legislature
about considering legislation for
community colleges in the same way it
might for large residential campuses we
do not have the traditional Residence
Life core with thousands of 18 to 22
year olds spending 24 hours a day seven
days a week 40 weeks a year living
together with the college or university
acting in local parentice for these
students we care deeply about student
mental health but the root to supporting
that is vastly different for us than the
residential four-year
campuses for instance ccs does not have
the same type of all-encompassing
residential life programs that a
four-year college has the vast majority
of our students live at home and commute
to campus of our seven colleges only one
an HG here in conquer has dormitories
and about 9% of its students live on
campus that's about 350 out of
4,000 another Lakes Region community
college offers apartment style living
adjacent to campus with about 60
students in the apartments out of 800
enrolled
Community College institutions do not
have the scope of on-campus mental
health services including the Staffing
to manage triage and short-term
stabilization and treatment nor do we
have psychiatrists who can prescribe and
monitor medications that are
increasingly part of the treatment for
mental health issues often already
identified while students are still in
high school the mandatory fees used to
support these services at most forear
institutions would create an additional
barrier to both both postsecondary
education and the intended care for most
of the students served by community
colleges the Partnerships that this
legislation envisions actually mandates
would create unique challenges for
community colleges in rural areas
requiring providers to be available and
sufficiently staffed to support
referrals and willing to accept payment
consistent with the resources of our
students many of whom are eligible for
pel Grants and likely to be insured
through expanded medicaid or potentially
uninsured we do have privacy concerns
particularly in the evaluation section
of the bill and we have academic freedom
concerns with respect to language about
integrating mental health awareness
curricula into courses and
seminars when our campuses are faced
with identical mandates to those
envisioned for larger and more
comprehensive campus environments the
result tends to be the imposition of
policies and compliance requirements
that are unrealistic and not well
aligned or developed to fit the needs
and experiences of our students it's
also worth asking whether the state
currently has or in the future expects
to have sufficient Mental Health
Resources particularly again in rural
areas to support the linkage agreements
required in the bill for example pre
pandemic in Sullivan County the weight
was more than 12 weeks to be seen for
all non-crisis mental health
issues we ask also that you pay
attention to the fiscal note for the
community colleges there would be a very
large cost to creating and sustaining
the programming and other requirements
of the bill the very specific and
prescriptive requirements could also
prevent us from optimizing other kinds
of supports that would be useful and
accessible for our
population thank you and I'm happy to
take
questions thank you uh Shannon I got one
question for you um the effective date
of this legislation is 60 days after
passage do you believe the community
college system will be able to put this
into effect and do it efficiently and
effectively within this within the time
period of going in effect uh no
representative lad I think that would be
unworkable
thank you very much uh Mr chair and um
and thank you very much M Reed for being
with us today um uh first a quick
followup to uh to the chair's um uh
question and then I have another
question but but do you think um um U
some of the policies and procedures that
are outlined in this bill could be put
in place by not necessarily A 60-day
effective date but but perhaps um uh
some uh down the road maybe July 1st
2023 or
2024 thank you representative luno I
circulated this bill to our college
student affairs offices and suggested
that this could provide the foundation
for a dialogue about what we are doing
what we could be doing what are some
evidence-based practices that are in
this bill or or maybe even not in this
bill um that we could be looking at to
support our students and so I think that
um this bill certainly will have
prompted a a a very thorough um launch
of or a launch of very thorough
conversations about what it is we we can
do um without kind of going through it
section by section I think there are
certainly some things
we we we have in place that are similar
to what's required some things that
would be very very difficult such as you
know the the the idea of of peer support
groups that's a great idea but peer
support groups are historically very
difficult to um to sustain
you may be able to create them with an
initial impetus but sustaining those
over time particularly with community
college students who are often they're
working their parents um H having that
kind of an ongoing um infrastructure if
you will is something that I think would
be would be very challenging right so so
you know I guess I would say that to an
extent some of these things are are are
doable or already in in various ways um
being being looked at tella health is
one thing that we were able to bring
bring on during the pandemic that that I
think we're looking at is this something
that is being utilized and something we
should sustain um but it definitely has
his Spar and and um and
thank thank you very very much Mr chair
and and and thanks Shannon um for that I
mean I'm what I'm sort of poking at is
is you know whether or not something
like this could even be amended um in a
way where where it could maybe um um um
coincide with with some of the
discussions that that you've you've
already had prior to and maybe after you
know the introduction of of of this bill
but but the the the question that sort
of comes up and I think you know you you
uh you talked about alluded to
it a little bit too is the um is is how
um um you know how how various you know
mental health U conditions disease um uh
affects not only students and their
families but also affects the colleges
themselves and and I don't even want to
try to to
quantify um how it affects you know a a
student and their their families but but
how about the colleges have have there
been studies either among our own
colleges or or maybe other public or
private schools in terms of uh the the
actual costs of of mental health on a
college campus and and how that affects
um campus
budgets thank you for the question there
a couple parts to that I think certainly
there have been surveys there's been
research done I I'm not aware of
anything that quantifies the effect um
of mental health issues on college
campuses or quantifies the the cost of
combating um you know Mental Health
issues and mental health challenges you
mentioned whether there was a
possibility to potentially amend this
bill to get at some of you know some of
the practices that we'd like to see put
in place I think the danger of putting
anything in legislation is then that's
what you do and there if other things
develop that may be more useful more
effective more relevant um you're sort
of stuck with what's what's been placed
in legislation I I think that one
strength of our institutions is we are
um continually trying to take the the of
our student body and and figure out what
students need what we can external
Partners you know mental health um
providers in our regions can provide via
you know linkages and referrals and
continually evolve and iterate that as
circumstance shift so I guess I would
caution you about considering you know
what might we pull from this or retain
here to keep in legislation because I
think that that you create sort of
different set of problems doing that you
you also create a a significant
administrative lift in terms of
reporting tracking monitoring the
specific things that you put in the bill
and and that's um institutional effort
that may be better used in other ways as
pertains to Student mdal Health sure
great great thank thank you very much
appreciate that further further
questions yes representative Mullen
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Miss
Reed for coming in today um does the
community college system currently have
a a sort of predictable
or formal outreach program for students
who are experiencing mental health
issues and is part of that if it does um
how do students learn how to access the
resources that are already available
thank you good question um in student
orientations we do we do bring up the
topic of mental health we do talk about
and and throughout the semester kind of
make um available information about
linkages and external resources um we we
don't at our campuses have a great deal
of infrastructure for for uh counseling
um or kind of direct support direct
provision of mental health services so a
lot of what we do is through
Partnerships
further questions from the community
college
system thank you very
much Tom Cronin your next University
system New
Hampshire good afternoon again Mr
chairman uh Tom Cronin director of
government relations for the University
system uh I'm pleased today to be with
my colleague uh Marlin Collingwood who
is the interim VP for communications
enrollment and student life at Plymouth
State um so let me just start by saying
the university system adamantly agrees
with the concerns of the sponsor uh I
think we hear this across the state uh
we are under no illusions that this
isn't a critically important issue
facing higher education in the country
fouryear higher education in the country
in New Hampshire is no different um I
thought what we could do today if it
would be helpful for the committee would
actually to turn it over to Marlon for a
few minutes to talk about exactly some
of the work we are doing uh in his case
specifically at Plymouth but he can also
speak to a larger University system lens
to try and address this issue currently
um and then maybe I could take a couple
minutes after Marlin speaks just to walk
through some of the concerns we have
with this bill uh as drafted and then of
course we'd be happy to take
questions
your thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee for allowing us to be here I'm
Marlin Collingwood I'm the inum vice
president of communications enrollment
and student life at Plymouth State
University in beautiful Plymouth New
Hampshire um I want to say a couple
things one is all of the universities in
the system are dedicated to the
emotional physical and mental health of
our students right what this bill uh
addresses is really really important we
had the unfortunate situation uh last
year at this time in having a student
suicide on campus uh it was very very
difficult it was very very difficult for
for all of the students it was difficult
obviously for the family of this student
uh and I have been talking to them and
continue to be in touch with them uh
over the past year what I can tell you
is we take this very seriously and have
been addressing the issue so two and a
half years ago Plymouth State University
uh became a part of an organization
called the Jed Jed campus the Jed
Foundation is uh an organization a
nonprofit organization that was founded
about a decade Ago by uh a Silicon
Valley uh executive and his wife whose
son Jed died by suicide on a Texas
college campus they dedicated a great
deal of time and significant resources
to starting this Foundation which is
based purely upon helping colleges and
universities deal with and promote the
mental health of students Plymouth State
University signed on with the Jed
Foundation two and a half years ago that
began a three-year process with them and
at the end of this year in
2023 we will be a Jed certified campus
there're about 133 Jed certified
campuses across the country UNH is a Jed
certified campus and now Plymouth state
will be as well what that means is we
had a team from the Jed Foundation come
into campus two and a half years ago
they sat with uh a steering committee
that was made up of Faculty staff
community members from the town of
Plymouth often times our students are
employed and live off campus so they're
dealing with the community uh and
students themselves and parents they sat
with us they looked at everything we
were doing and then they came back with
recommendations on what we should
Implement over the next three years we
have begun implementing those
recommendations and I'm here to tell you
that a couple of them have been very
successful uh and not only that we are
actually looking at how successful they
are from the data so when the Jed
Foundation came one of the first things
we did was what's called an the Healthy
Mind survey which is done through the
University of Michigan it's a national
survey on college student mental health
that was sent out to all of our students
we had about 66% response rate which is
very high for a survey sent to college
students probably high for survey sent
to anyone um but they identified the
needs that they had they identified
where they had found help for those
needs and what else they needed one of
the also one of the important things was
they identified for us how easy or hard
it was for them to access the services
that we offered we took the results of
that survey and began to implement the
recommendations of the Jed Foundation
the number one recommendation of the Jed
Foundation was that we do a better job
of promoting the services that we have
so we adopted at their recommendation uh
an a phone app obviously that's what a
college student needs it's called
wellcheck it's a national app uh that's
uh supported by the Jed foundation and
we launched that last spring and about
71 % of our students right now have
downloaded The Well Check app they use
it on their phone and it's really a
self-help app but also provides
opportunities for them to learn about
mental health opportunities across
campus so it sends them uh they check in
and they can check their basically a
wellness check every day that's for
their own right and it tells you if you
if you're at this level you ought to
think about going to a stress release uh
uh uh opportunity that we have maybe you
want to go take a yoga class but most
importantly every day it goes out to
those students here's what's happening
today related to mental and emotional
well-being and it also is a way for them
to contact directly our Counseling
Center uh and we are pleased our
students are using that and we can also
check that app if they give us
permission to see how they're doing and
that's very helpful for our counselors
who are seeing students on a regular
basis uh at our Counseling Center the
second thing we did was we did what was
called fres check day it's a national uh
day that is uh recommended to happen on
the very first day of classes on any
college campus and it's basically a day
when classes start where we focus on
mental health and we had about 1,600
students attend our first fresh check
day last August 31st the day classes
started the idea being that it's a a
kind of a fair if you will and students
uh can go and talk to and see all of the
various resources that are happening
there um we were able to get our
athletes involved in that so all that
e efforts and again the idea is we care
so much about this that we're going to
emphasize it on the very first day
classes begin it was very successful and
we'll be doing that again uh and then
the final thing that uh we'll be doing
is we'll be doing another uh Healthy
Mind survey that will go out this spring
and it will look at the difference what
we see in the difference of all of the
things we've done in the last two and a
half years to what students are seeing
today and I think that's going to be
really important for us and part of the
Jed campus program is that we will do
that Healthy Mind survey every two years
uh and we are committed to doing that
and then I know in this bill IT
addresses the issue of reaching out to
and and having contracts with local
providers very very important um I'm not
sure that having that prescripted in a
piece of legislation makes the most
sense but I can tell you and I sit on
the board of the Lakes Region Mental
Health uh organization and they are one
of our partners that we've used for
years we have a very successful
relationship with them uh our Counseling
Center uh already um you know recommends
students and and actually makes
referrals directly to counselors and
therapists and support groups that are
part of lakes Region's mental health and
that program has been very successful it
allows our students to literally walk
across campus across Highland Street
into the Plymouth uh office of Lakes
Region mental health so it's really
connected to our campus from that
standpoint so I think it's important for
you to know what we are doing that we
have students who are very active in
this uh and and I believe we are working
hard to move to the next level and I can
tell you that both keen and UNH are on
that same track happy to answer any
questions anyone might have are there
any questions yes
Tanner thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um do you do any
training of your staff or we do for
residential uh counselors and and
particularly in mental health for St yes
so right right today actually I think
this afternoon at three o'clock our uh
our our residents life team is back on
campus right classes start next Tuesday
so all of our uh resident uh life teams
including the community directors who
the professional staff that live in the
building and all of the community
advisers who live in the floor are
getting Mental Health First Aid training
this afternoon and that we do that in
cooperation with nami uh and we do that
in cooperation with Lakes Region mental
health in addition our student facing
professional staff so that would include
folks in the registar folks in the
dining hall folks in uh you know Student
Life they all get suicide prevention
training as well because our uh the Jed
Foundation has told us be surprised the
people that are most likely to see that
a student might be struggling it's a
cafeteria worker and a building service
worker the person that cleans the floor
so you get to see them every morning and
the person that serves you breakfast
lunch and dinner so we've gone to Great
Lengths to make sure that they're part
of our team and are trained as
well go ahead so I think that that's
it's a good segue just kind of some of
the concerns we have with the
legislation so by our count the bill
probably would mandate somewhere around
a dozen requirements on the state's
public colleges and universities in
preparation for this hearing work with
Marlin and others to prepare for this
hearing we did go through those right
and we think we're in a good position on
many of them already um that's a great
example you've heard Marlin talk about
websites You' heard him talk about uh
orientation about uh surveys we are
doing those in some degree at some
variation on all of our campuses we do e
and flow based on what we think works
and what doesn't and that's important we
think to our ability to continue to
address this issue amongst our student
body we one concern for example is the
bill necessitates uh are evaluating
these programs but then doesn't give us
the flexibility to stop doing stuff that
doesn't work in favor of things that do
um so that's one of one of our concerns
uh if I could quickly a couple others
the bill speaks the idea of an expert
panel um that would be required at each
of either the schools or at the the
board of trustee level that wasn't
entirely clear but either way it sort of
is seeming to suggest we need an extra
layer of attention on top of the good
work that's already going on on each of
the campuses certainly more help is
always nice but as we've heard multiple
times in the committee and other places
we do focus on administrative burden if
we think we're doing the job well
perhaps that's not again a great use of
of funds strategic Partnerships we've
talked about a couple of times things we
we want to do we do I think do at many
of our campuses shortages of providers
is clear um as much as it would be great
to have them uh we can't make them
appear out of thin air um and at the
same time in other cases we try and stop
a little bit short of formal contractual
obligations with providers out of
concern for conf conflict of interest
appearances of favoritism and other
concerns like that and this bill would
actually not only require us to contract
but then open up our student bodies to
advertising and otherwise from some of
these external groups which is a little
bit of a concern uh I think it might
have been representative Woodcock
earlier asked a question about private
colleg universities this bill does not
apply to the private colleges
universities in the state um they are
obviously uh facing this issue in the
same way we are and I'm sure our just as
dedicated to it um but that might be a a
question and obviously there's no fiscal
support in this bill right now our
fiscal note I think was about a quarter
million dollars a year um to go beyond
where we are right now I know shanon
mentioned Community College syst was
much higher um that is obviously a
concern and the fact that it will force
us again to do a prescriptive set of
things at more money than we are
spending now and not give us the
flexibility to adjust as we we we hope
we could uh down the line uh maybe just
to close you know representative luno
asked a good question about where this
could go uh I think there was a
committee or a commission a couple years
ago perhaps I think actually
representative Corell you might have
chaired it looking at this exact issue
in K through 12 schools certainly that
is something I think we would love to
participate in would love to bring the
private college universities along with
community college system and have those
conversations and really think about
what are the discreet focused areas
where either we aren't maybe meeting
what we'd like to we'd like to be able
to do more and how do we work together
as a state to make those Partnerships
happen that can be successful for all of
our students but one that is a little
bit more focused and a little bit more
tailored to where we all agree there is
a need um so maybe with that I'll stop
it again I know we're a little over but
happy to answer Mr Cronin and and Mr
Collingwood I I have a question on your
handout you've provided us on a second
page going down several paragraphs it
reads in conducting a survey of campuses
in preparation for this hearing we
established that we are meeting or
exceeding nearly all of the requirements
of the bill
already then you drop down a couple
sentences the only way to reallocate
resources to evolving best practices
will be through changes in State law can
you please identify what you mean by
best practices and what would have to be
changed in state law is it finances or
is it some other statutory area that
we've been dealing like with earlier
today sorry so to be clear that is
assuming 1648 passed so if 1648 would
pass and say these are all the things
you must do to address student mental
health if we were to see for example
that I think Keen state may have offered
an example where they for a while were
doing a student survey they were getting
very low turnout on that survey Marlin
pointing out 60 something percent is
outstanding when you get below a certain
threshold surveys are no longer valuable
Keen was paying for this survey they
wanted to get this information it wasn't
working for them they discontinued use
of it we would not be allowed to
discontinue use of a survey like that
should 1648 become one so on followup
they just trying to get some
clarifications on this changes in state
law what would be changed in state law
adopting this or sorry yeah I apologize
there's confusion this testimony is
essentially saying if you were to adopt
1648 it would then take us changes in
state law we'd have to go back and amend
1648 as is now Statute in order to do
things differently than what the bill
prescribes we do right now we don't need
any changes in state law and we'd rather
we didn't put these prescriptive requir
into state law but if we did put
prescriptive requirements in state law
we feel like we would need to go back
and ask you to say Keen is not having
success with the survey we'd like to not
do it anymore but law says we have to
right now we do not have that problem
thank you further
questions per and lak
US yes thank you can you tell me what
the name of that phone app is and do you
have to be a college
student uh well you do have to be you
have to have a Plymouth state email
address to be able to use it but it's
called wellcheck w l c c and you can
look it up and find it online uh and uh
but if you had a Ply State email address
I could let you be a member right now
thank you very
much Cornell Thank you thank you for
taking my question is Plymouth the only
one that's doing the the well check in
the app or so so Plymouth State and Keen
State both use well Che right now I know
that UNH has a different app that you're
using I'm not sure which which it is uh
and then I know that uh uh univers uh
University of New Hampshire went through
the Jed process about four years ago I
don't know if Keen State's looking at
that or not but I do know and I guess
the other thing I would say to emphasize
what Tom said not only is is this going
to require you know the the system to do
everything it's also going to require
each campus to do things the same and
that doesn't work for us um I have a
very different student body um 53% of my
students are first generation college
students every year 55% of them are
fully pel eligible which mean they come
from a very lowincome families they have
very different mental health needs than
the students might have at UNH or at
keen and we need to be able to have the
flexibility to do what works not just
for everybody but that works
specifically and is prescriptive to our
campus and I think you said you follow
up I said you had a partnership withouth
um Mental Health Center with the Lakes
Region mental health yes yes and I think
un Manchester I think one with the
mental health C Manchester yes and I
know Keen State I believe has a similar
partnership but again they work for us
right this bill would really make those
would for be the best for our
students or best for the needs that they
have
does so you SAR with
providers relationships how those
relationships are they Contra are they
we agree this is a good place to set
services to but instead of being one of
sort of mutual partnership legislation
forces us into it when may only have few
Ops and no matter whe what having a
partnership there's still a lack of
Provider so even if you have a
partnership doesn't mean that somebody's
going to get to that's right thank you
are there further questions
yes representa Mullen then represent
wood thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you again gentlemen um Mr Cronin I
can hear the pride in Mr collingwood's
voice about what's happening at Plymouth
State uh I have a two-part question one
is uh is there someone in the University
system that oversees the mental health
of all if you will to determine whether
or not keen and UNH and UNH Manchester
are equally as proud of what they're
doing in mental health
services and um I if there is not how do
the colleges
determine what needs Plymouth has as
opposed to what needs Keane and and
Durham
have yeah I'm happy to address that if
if that's okay so um yes me student
mental health is an important agenda
item every time we have a board of
trustees meeting uh it falls under the
academic academic Excellence committee
and from that group there is a group of
uh Student Life team that meets monthly
it's a steering committee that's made up
of um my counterparts and actually the
heads of our counseling centers and so
we meet monthly and we share resources
we share best practices we talk about
specific issues we might be be having uh
and so it's uh it's been that's been
around for about a year and a half now
and uh that committee has worked really
well for us to be able to really know
what uh I mean for instance you know
there are a lot of what we're doing that
uh my counterparts at keen and un have
said we want to come up and see about
that we'd like to look at a fresh check
day how do we do that so representative
I think that that
groupes yes thank you brother thank you
gentlemen for taking my question Mr
calling with I will reiterate as my
friend to the right here said thank you
so much I appreciate your uh positive
and enthusiastic support in such a
difficult topic uh just one very little
small piece that uh the panther place or
the other colleges around the state do
they um you have any peer support groups
I know that the the uh originator of
legislation was looking primarily for
peer support I didn't hear you mention
that in your things or just just quick
piece so uh um I will say this we do not
um peer support groups are not
necessarily the best kind of support
groups for mental health okay um unlike
Alcoholics Anonymous or Narcotics
Anonymous uh in which you come in and
you share um uh the same experiences
right with different different details
oftentimes mental health uh issues are
very different and and not something
that you're willing or wanting to share
with a group I believe that any peer
peer support groups that would happen
would we would want them to have a
professional that is running them which
then becomes another issue in which I
have you know six counselors at my
Counseling Center who are literally
filled up with one-on-one appointments
um we do do peer groups but they're not
necessarily support groups we do peer
groups on um breathing techniques we do
peer groups on anti how to how to how to
get rid of your anxiety those kinds of
things but it's very different to have a
peer support group that's literally
having 10 people who are depressed come
in and talk to each other that tends not
to be a a a really um
medical advice kind of situation that's
very different from a group of people
who have cancer or who have and it's not
something that's actually recommended
very highly thank you very much thank
you repr I appreciate it represent
Hopson thank you thank you Mr chair and
uh thank you Mr Collingwood and Mr
Cronin for your testimony today I wasn't
sure if I should uh bring this up or not
it's um I wanted to know if uh Mr Cronin
if you were familiar with um the uh UNH
I'm sorry just lost it here shoot um I
think it was the um department of
disability there's a woman there Heidi
cluder who is working with one of my
constituents um they have a recovery
it's live free recovery and they have a
peer-to-peer group support already in
place for substance abuse and
co-occurring situations so I don't know
if it's applicable or if it's a a
structure that you might want to look at
but have you heard of that before so I
have vaguely heard of the work the IOD
is doing on this issue and I think it's
a good opportunity to follow up on
Martin's or Marlin's answer the last
question and a couple questions from the
representatives you know I think of the
opportunities we have at the University
right now or un system right now is
three very different campuses located in
three distinct regions of the state all
with different student bodies all again
recognizing the sincere importance of
this issue but being able to come at it
from a few different directions have
conversations up to the Board of
Trustees level on down through various
committees and then student affairs
executive committee working hand and
glove to try and understand what each of
our universities is doing to tackle this
issue so I do think there are peer
support uh groups on both keen and I
know at UNH we recently started a
program and we're trying to see how it
fares so what we're that group is going
to do is come back and say all right
this worked this is what the research
says this is what best practice and
evidence say this is the suggestion for
how we go forward I don't think there's
a civil Silver Bullet solution to this
and I think we probably would say sure
if money and resources were no option
we'd love to do all of it and throw it
all at the wall that's not reality
however and instead we're in a place
where we're trying
standing
best practices and what we're hearing
from our students and families Works um
so I think that is hopefully a response
to to all those questions on on how we'd
like to proceed and again a chance to
talk in more detail through a study
commission or otherwise I think you
would likely hear colleagues at Plymouth
Kean UNH many of the Community College
systems many of the private universities
in the state all with the same passion
Marlin has for this issue uh coming in
to talk about some ways we can try and
make it better for
everyone
Tom I got one last question here further
reading your letter here uh you must
have done some kind of a national search
to find out what's going on throughout
the country in regard to this horrible
issue it says uh this has been a
challenge in Illinois where the bill
passed in late
2019 but has not been funded leaving
campuses in
alert uh did you see any other states
which have passed this and successful in
implementing is the is the money you go
on the next PA it's basically a money
issue um what's the situation throughout
other than Illinois here so really just
some Googling around trying to
understand the origins of the bill um
the way the language was written did
seem pretty prescriptive and made me
think that perhaps there were other
states looking at this I saw Illinois
was sort of the one state that had
passed it again a couple years ago and
and now they have yet to fund it um I
think it might have been proposed in New
Jersey but please don't hold me to that
uh again it was kind of just the first
few things that came up on a Google
search thank you are there further
questions for the University system
thank you very much for your time thank
you what we doing
Mike is representative Eric Gallagher
here or he's not a
representative yes he is yes he is
co-sponsor
yeah welcome Eric hi um yeah I'm Eric
gagher ma 15 that's conquered w six and
um so I don't really have as much to say
in um the way of specific wordings that
the previous testifiers were talking
about I'm mostly just here to share my
personal story of why I support this
bill
so I went to George Washington
University in DC from 2009 to 2013 and
while I was there I
developed some mental health conditions
of my own and um there was a university
Counseling Center I was able to receive
counseling
services and um able to get a diagnosis
and that enabled me to get the resources
I needed for from the disability Center
at the
college um to be able to graduate
successfully
and just my
whole one of the
main pieces of feedback I'd give to that
experience was just how isolating it was
to be being just one onone with a
counselor if I hadn't known
that there were other
people at my college who were going
through the same thing as me and that we
could exchange tips with and commiserate
with each other that um with also there
being a counselor there at the same time
I think that would have
been a lot more helpful than just trying
to work through it work through it all
all by myself um so one question might
be
um well why why peer support groups
specifically for University students why
not just send them
to existing mental health support groups
out in the
community um so after returning
home I I actually tried that I tried um
signing up for a support group through
River band uh here and conquered
and it was not a group of my peers it
was like
mostly it it was it it um people people
in the general public with mental
illness and um mental health issues um
tend not to to have the exact same
problems as the mental health problems
that college can create so that's why
um that's why I think it would be good
to have peer support groups specifically
for college students so that way they
can understand the help help each other
with the problems relate specifically to
college that people from the rest of the
public might not necessarily be
experiencing um
and so that's about all I have to say
and I'll take any questions thank you
very much
are there questions for the
representative not see any hands thank
you very much for your
testimony are there any further folks in
the public that would like to speak on
this issue or this bill not any we close
this
hearing and we're going to take a short
four or five minute break so we can all
get up stretch
and we'll resolve that get back here in
about five minutes thank
you
another
I was to say I don't see
anyes
e
yeah I
know
night
andv I I'm
thinking study might motion for that
follow up in a while see
you
s
e
for
okay you're going to have to chair this
one yep we started
out
1313 I'll just read this quickly and be
done with it so we can get going yeah
yeah we fell a little bit behind yeah
well the afternoon I expect to with some
of these bills
yeah
so school facility planning and
development program in the Department of
Education I don't know anything about
that bill 1685 want to create a new
Department
really we're having a hard time funding
the one we got
yeah thinking on that last I wouldn't I
could see an in study motion so we could
always come back and revisit that you
know later in the spring or something
and see you know what's
happening see the the last
bill yeah that has to final does it yeah
pretty big Bill
yeah
e
spe
cord supposed to be
there
I think we're about ready to uh resume
um and we will resume with House Bill
1313 relative to the rights to freedom
from discrimination in higher
education and uh the prime sponsor is uh
ready to go and so we welcome the
testimony of Representative
lad thank you very much uh Mr chairman
and members of the House Education
committee for the record my name is Rick
lad I uh come from hail New Hampshire
and I'm here today to speak and
introduce HB
13113 on June 25 2021 Governor sonunu
signed hb2 into law New Hampshire became
one of six to prohibit instruction that
certain individuals are inherently
Superior to people of another age sex
gender identity sexual orientation race
Creed color and other conditions so
stated in the Bill the law further
states that an individual by virtue of
certain identifying conditions such as
the color of one's skin is inherently
racist sexist or oppressive whether
consciously or
unconsciously the law does not prohibit
discussing as a part of a larger course
of academic construction the historical
existence of ideas and subjects
identified in this section HB 1313 adds
public postsecondary institutions to the
definition of public public employer
that was passed back in hb2 for the
purpose of prohibiting discrimination in
higher
education be it being a public employee
in grades K through 12 or an instructor
at the postsecondary levels the law
applies to all one should not convey to
any individual that his or her color
creed or other defining characteristics
is inherently racist sexist or
oppressive whether consciously or
unconsciously
any instructor aligning and
communicating one's own vision of race
relations with the national narrative
that uses diversity and inclusion as its
platform is
unacceptable it is the teachers or the
professor's responsibility to carefully
weigh words and actions and thoughtfully
engage in civil discussion Public
Employee should reflect that reflect the
approved curriculum of the institution
and not personal belief the false
National narrative that Pro professes
that all states suffer from centuries of
white privilege white supremacy and
systematic racis racism does not reflect
New Hampshire any instruction promoting
that RAC racism is Alive and Well in New
Hampshire does not reflect postsecondary
education in our state nor does it
accurately portray our residents
particularly those who have been here
for Generations nor does it address the
fact fact that we have invest invested
efforts to attract more individuals and
families to New Hampshire increasing
diversity by nearly
75% in the decade in closing we should
not forget Dr Martin Luther King's
famous speech and advice to the
nation I have a dream that my four
little children will one day live in a
nation where they will not be judged by
the color of their skin but by the
content of their character as a parent
and grandparent I ask that schools and
postsecondary institutions teach our
young people to think but not tell them
what to think advocating CRT is
discriminatory and does not reflect neap
way of life and certainly doesn't align
Dr King's Vision it does the opposite by
pitting people against each other thank
you Mr
chair thank you
representative are there questions from
the committee representative
Porter
thankes question can you tell me do you
believe
ASAS I think we have a law in place that
we passed with hp2 and now I'm asking
that that same law be put in place for
the other end of education postsecondary
education but my question is do you
believe in such implicit
bias because implicit bias is is not
allowed under the my understanding we
have to deny that that exists I want to
know if you believe it exists I don't
deny that we have a history that has
good bad ugly points throughout it I
agree 100% as a teacher myself I was
teaching when I was in Alaska that ens
slavery as done by the Russian when they
came over to Alaska was absolutely not
acceptable and a a portion of our
history which should be you know
corrected and it was I also taught the
Holocaust and reading a book right now
dealing with the tattooist of owitz
which is a wonderful book that all
should read we have a history in this
country that is developing and but I
don't believe I should be tagged or you
should be tagged or anybody in this room
be tagged with the idea that you are
racist because of our past our past is
our
past I have we can learn from it yes the
definition that I'm reading here from
perception.
org what does it mean to have an
implicit
bias we have a bias when rather than
being neutral we have a preference for
or aversion to a person or group of
people thus we use implicit bias to
describe when we have udes toward people
or Associates stereotypes with them
without our conscious
knowledge do you believe that that I
think
that as you grow and one acquires the
wisdom through life as I did when I
moved to Alaska to a small community
where I was in the minority my younger
daughter grew up learning how to speak
upic I didn't see one person different
from another person person yes there are
people you like and you don't like
that's in every society however I didn't
see it in the way in the format in the
direction you're
going then you're a better person than I
am representative lad well thank you for
the
compliment uh thank you other questions
from the committee for representative
lad seen none oh I'm sorry sorry I
missed you please proceed
representative thank you Mr chair and
thank you representative for taking my
question would it be
allowed in an elementary
school to illustrate what discrimination
is by for
example
allowing children with only brown eyes
to uh line up first for lunch or to get
drinks at the water fountain for lunch
as opposed to the blue-eyed children and
then the next day reverse it and lot of
the blue-eyed children as opposed to the
browney
children I've seen that occur in schools
and with younger children and that has a
reverse effect as well and that will
oftentimes pit children against children
who don't really
understand and I I I think that that's
something I wouldn't do I wouldn't line
a lot of kids up and say okay John and
and Susan you pick the kids in your team
and the person standing there last is
the one that's always Hur that's not
correct I also believe that when we say
that we're going to separate based upon
a physical
characteristic and who knows that young
child may go home saying I don't have
blue eyes and I'm not the same as that
person has brown
eyes I don't think young kids see that
difference I don't think young kids know
that when they come to school we teach
them these these discriminatory actions
by some of our actions we should be
teaching our schools what's happened in
our past which is negative I agree but I
don't think we should be doing an
activity such as that and giving them
that experience so they take home the
wrong message and they start believing
the wrong
message I think there's other ways to
teach what you're trying to teach and
what you're trying to do through that
activity uh representative Mullen
thank you representative cordelli and
thank you representative vad for taking
the question um so postsecondary
students are college students is am I
correct in assuming that that's what the
term means in this bill representative
fled yes that means that there the
pupils are K through 12 and those
students yeah graduated from high school
okay so they're they're beyond K through
12 yes um so in this in this bill it
says that no pupil in elementary or
second and no postsecondary educational
student shall be taught
instructed
inculcated or compelled to express a
belief in or support for any one of the
following and then I don't have the list
in front of me but I mean we basically
know that it's the sort of divisive
concept
language that follows at this at this
point correct everything that's in the
highlighted dark area is new everything
that is in the uh nonbold font is what
is in law right now okay so could I have
a followup representative cordelli thank
you
so by adding this to the statute by
adding postsecondary to the
statute are we saying then that
colleges in college classes people can't
discuss critical race Theory no we're
not saying
that we're not we're not saying we're
not saying that you can't be
teaching uh um issues that are in our
past that have dealt with race you can
te but you're not going to Advocate it
as your personal
belief
one one more follow up and I promise
I'll get i'll get off of this got the
promise I I I I wouldn't have given it
representative if I didn't mean it um
so I I guess I'm having a hard time with
the uh the nebulousness of the word
instructed or taught at the
postsecondary level because it would
seem to me that we would not we would
want adults to to be able to talk about
anything in an instructional situation
we would want them to use critical
thinking to draw their own conclusions
at the post-secondary level uh a and so
I'm
wondering how this cannot be a violation
of someone's freedom of speech we have
to look at the rest of that law that was
passed last year which you don't see
here and when it talks about
any one or more of the following and
then you go down and you'll see the
areas which this bill talks to which I
spoke to at the beginning of my
presentation those are the issues which
were were directing this bill this
postsecondary education instruction
towards but my question to you and it's
the same question representative
cordelli it's not a new one my question
to you is
um why would we want to prohibit adults
from talking about anything in their
postsecondary education that they have
paid for and
are capable of formulating their own
opinions I mean we're talking college
students why would we want to do that
would that not be considered curtailing
the freedom of
speech I would just love to be have the
opportunity to attend and join some of
these classrooms where I have been told
by college students you Echo back
exactly what you want to that what that
Professor wants and you'll get your Aid
you show a Divergent way of
thinking and hang it up I think that we
got to be very careful that we don't
narrow down the where we're going with
our instruction in a postsecondary level
by coming across and saying I as the
instructor and advocating this and
pushing
this I as a young student would be kind
of like wow I guess I know how I can get
out of this class I'll just Echo what
that individual's saying if I go the
other way I know where I'm going to be
uh so I think that there are certain
ways of communicating we don't want to
teach them what to think we want to
teach them how to think and we ought to
be able to respect persp persectives
from different different uh
directions I'm not sure that you
answered my question representative but
thank you for the attempt you're welcome
representative
anner thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative lad for taking the
question um I think there has been
nothing since I've been a legislator
that has caused more of my constituents
and particularly teacher friends of mine
uh to contact me and talk to me uh and
we've wrestled with this about this bill
and you're making it even I in my
opinion um even harder on teachers uh
and now even College professors um and
I'm wondering because you were an
administrator and because you were a
teacher given what we have
here um How do you feel a person in a
classroom uh would be when some student
in the class asks a question that enters
into this critical race Theory diversive
concept nebulous Cloud that we're
talking about how how would you counsel
a teacher as to how to handle that you
can respond to a question you don't have
to say this is my way of thinking you
can respond to a question you can have
open
dialogue I I don't object to that and I
don't think that that a college
professor should however when you come
out and you're advocating for that or
forming committees or groups to work on
subjects like this on this topic you're
advocating for it you're pushing it and
that's something we don't want to push
discrimination because that's exactly
what it is it's ending up pitting
individuals against other individuals
when we we uh didn't need to go that
direction I believe our society is
changing and it's changing for the
better we're all more aware and it's
moving forward this legislation or CRT
or any of these projects that have come
out are just I think tearing the fabric
of this country apart and I think there
is are different opinions on the
committee right now on this topic and
you're you you're welcome to have your
own
opinion well thank thank I respect thank
you for that um I'm glad I have still
free speech yes you do we all
do any other uh questions for the
representative um maybe if I could ask
representative um it's my recollection
that the existing statute uh currently
has a provision uh expli explicitly
stating that um uh subjects um as we've
been discussing um can be part of any
academic
instruction that would I think uh or
should satisfy Any teacher concerns am
am I correct in my recollection of that
statute that is in law and you are
correct representative
cordelli thank you very much for your
testimony I'm sorry repes representative
Ford thank
you representative one question has
puzzled me throughout this entire
discussion is never seems to be a
definition of a
theory and that what is often advanced
in terms of a theory is Advanced as
fact and the theory is as I've always
been taught something that is not yet
proven and so I wonder about part of the
issue here isn't that people who are
perhaps not as skillful in their
teaching but are teaching the theory as
though
fact when in fact is nothing more than a
speculation the thing falls on its face
in terms of just rational
analysis I think that's well
stated thank you very
much seeing no further questions thank
you very much
representative
next uh person to
testify um is Devin chaffy from
ACLU thank you chairman and other
honorable memb members of this committee
for the record my name is Devon chaffy
and I'm the executive director of the
ACLU of New Hampshire which is a
nonprofit nonpartisan organization that
has been defending civil rights and
civil liberties in the state of New
Hampshire for over 50 years and I come
today uh before you today to testify an
opposition to HB uh 13113 as an
unconstitutional restriction on academic
freedom I'd like to start uh by quoting
an additional quote from Martin Luther
King Jr who wrote in 1967 that and I
quote whites it must frankly be said are
not putting in a mass effort to
re-educate themselves out of their
racial
ignorance Martin Luther King Jr went on
to say in 197 in
1967 that it is an aspect of their sense
of superiority that the white people of
America believe that they have so little
to to learn similarly he said in an
interview that the concept of Supremacy
is so embedded in white society that it
will take many years for color to cease
to be a judgmental factor I wanted to
include that additional poll because I
think it's very important to fully
understand um the teachings of Martin
Luther King what he was trying to
express and his indication that we were
going to be struggling with issues
related to race for decades to come and
that we had much learning and much
growth to
do I want to start by noting that the
band concept act that was was enacted in
hb2 last year specifically excluded
public state colleges and universities
from its scope um as was mentioned it
included an academic freedom exception
for faculty members and the New
Hampshire and Community College systems
in the academic setting and it appears
that HB 1313 is aiming to expand
specific provisions of the ban Concepts
act to apply to public state colleges
and
universities and indeed HB 13113 even
seems to subject Colley faculty to
lawsuits if they are perceived to
violate the ACT this in fact this
expansion which HB 1313 is attempting to
accomplish is simply said clearly a
violation of the US Constitution and the
First Amendment it is in fact a
violation of long-standing Supreme Court
precedent going back over 60 years
projecting academic freedom especially
in the University setting the you the US
Supreme Court stated in we versus the
state of New Hampshire that teachers and
students must always remain free to
inquire to study and to evaluate to gain
new maturity and understanding otherwise
our civilization will stagnate and die
again in 1978 the US Supreme Court made
clear that academic freedom though not
specifically not a specifically
enumerated constitutional right has long
been viewed as a special concern for the
First Amendment and more recently the
Supreme Court has made clear that
particularly in the University setting
exactly what HB 13113 is trying to
Target it is unquestionable that
Viewpoint based suppression of speech is
impermissible silencing a particular
Viewpoint here we're talking about
concepts related to racism and sexism
violates the first amendment
period moreover as it stands the ban
concept Act is so unclear and vague that
it fails to provide the necessary
guidance to Educators about what they
can and cannot include in their
courses HB 1313 would only compound this
defect by applying the ACT to public
colleges and universities again where
academic freedom is particularly
protected under the first amendment I
want to provide a little historical
context here the New Hampshire band
Concepts act includes four of the 10
band Concepts that were included in
president Trump's September 22nd 2020
executive order and a federal court
partially enjoined that
order finding the order to be and I
quote so vague that it was impossible
for plaintiffs to determine what conduct
is
prohibited so the court enjoined that
order which included four of the ban the
four ban Concepts that are included in
New Hampshire law because it was so
vague that there was no way for
potential plaintiffs to to understand
what the law was
prohibiting because of this vague
language and the stiff penalties and the
ban Concepts act some educators are
already right now avoiding important
topics concerning race and gender
because they fear being the subject of a
complaint or lawsuit from an angry
parent or student who doesn't like their
curriculum for
example is Tiffany juwels book this book
is anti-racist banned under the
ACT is it it's it's a New York Times
bestseller it's very widely read it's
pretty well
acclaimed is this something to uh to
speak to what a representative said
earlier that we don't want adults even
to be able to access in a university
setting what about stamped for kids
racism anti-racism and you is that
banned under the
ACT these are well acclaimed widely read
contemporary works but no one right now
knows if they're per permissible under
the ban Concepts act no one knows and
the state will not provide concrete
answers as to whether these specific
texts are covered or not and as a result
in order to avoid the acts penalties
which are pretty severe teachers are
currently right now pulling books like
this from staff and course instruction
out of fear of liability even if these
books may not necessarily be covered by
the act that is the definition of the
chill created by an unconstitutionally
vague
and it demonstrates the damage that such
chill can do in the
classroom it's important to understand
that under HB 1313 its applic and its
application of the ban Concepts penalty
to college professors that any college
student assigned a book perceiv received
as being prohibited by the ban Concepts
act anyone who assigns a book that that
they perceived is banned by the ACT
could file a superior court lawsuit
against the professor's school and
potentially the professor themselves
it's no wonder that educators are acting
out of caution and fear and because of
that students are missing out on
critically important discussions on race
and gender education focusing on Race
gender and diversity Equity inclusion
Concepts in classrooms provides a
multitude of benefits for students and
Society at large these discussions of
race and gender are particularly
important as New Hampshire becomes
rapidly more diverse as was Illustrated
in the recent release census in 2020
2020 instruction on race and gender
serves to close existing opportunity
gaps and inequalities faced by students
of color in New Hampshire and other
historically marginalized groups it also
helps these students to feel a better
sense of belonging in New Hampshire and
finally HB
13313 and its expansion of the ban
Concepts Act is put simply about
censorship censorship is a dangerous
Concept in universities we should be
allowing ideas to be discussed even
those we don't agree with so that
students are exposed to an alternative
perspective and taught to evaluate
issues for themselves this skill set is
necessary to educate the next generation
of adults who have critical thinking
skills and conveniently participate in
our
democracy New Hampshire should not Rob
students of the information ideas and
instructional approaches that prepare
them to engage in the just the type of
robust dialogue and analytical thinking
that is necessary to effectively
function as a citizen in America's
democratic system for these reasons I
respectfully urge the committee to
recommend that HB 1313 be inexpedient to
legislate and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you thank you any
questions yes representative
Moffet thank you Mr uh chair and thank
you for being here and for your
impassion testimony let me preface my
question by quickly pointing out that I
have a had a career in Academia as a
professor in the community college
system University system and elsewhere
to preface my question and uh I am very
much a First Amendment person and I'm
very much for freedom of speech in the
college classroom and I'm not sure where
I am on this bill at this time I want to
hear a lot more from everyone but my
question for you is with regard to the
to the fact that there are academic
people out there in New Hampshire and
everywhere who advocate in
classes they Advocate Advocate online in
journals and social media they advocate
for
ideologies for movements and for
people who favor the violent overthrow
of of our government they they to change
our government by any means
necessary so is
this is
this excuse me representative
luno so my question for you is is this
uh treasonous seditious uh behavior in
classrooms okay with with
you well I I I I thank you for your
question representative maet and thank
you for first of all for your your your
interest and dedication to the first
amendment I would love to continue this
conversation beyond the hearing um
especially given the particular concerns
that we have over the application of
this statute to the university setting
uh certainly uh you know I for one
believe that universities should
thoroughly vet their professors to make
sure that their professors are well
qualified and in line with with
University values uh I do not believe
that is the place of the New Hampshire
legislature to begin
legislating the type of conversations
and certainly the topics of
conversations that can or cannot be
discussed in classrooms I think
inevitably what we are going what you
will get from that and inevitably what
you have gotten from that type of
restriction in an academic setting in
other countries where there are
authoritarian regimes is a limited
ability for people to exchange ideas I
think that's a very dangerous road for
us to begin to go down
follow up so my my question simply was
you're okay with academics advocating
for the violent overthrow of our
government I'm sorry sir I don't I don't
know exactly what examples that you are
are are speaking to with regards to the
violent overthrow of our government I'm
not aware of any of those examples in
New Hampshire uh certainly and uh that
is not and I what I will say is that is
that is not the type of uh of activity
or discussion in classrooms that we are
seeing be being shut down by the
existing band Concepts law what we are
seeing being affected and I'm happy to
provide you with additional examples of
the types of conversations that
currently teachers are afraid to engage
in and the way that teachers are having
to change their approach to curriculum
currently in New Hampshire simply has to
do with the way that they are talking
about racism and sexism uh and and the
way that they um uh manifest themselves
whether throughout US history or
currently in existing Society or in
individual students lives and student
experiences those are the types of
things that we are see seeing in reality
being shilled here in New Hampshire by
the existing law and that we fear would
be chilled if this law were to expand to
the university system thank
you further
questions uh representative
Ford um and thank you for your
presentation today
useful it doesn't get at however in my
opinion a particular flaw in that whole
argument and it's flawed
reasoning we learned from many Greek
philosophers that something like just
because this follows it doesn't mean it
caused it the thing follows an idea so
for someone assert that someone who
looks like me who's white who's male
must therefore be implicitly racist all
the more so because I grew up in
Louisiana those become facts used to
butress their
assertion that I'm
racist and yet there's no
proof and they valid validate or is
invalidated by the flawed reasoning po
Hawk Ergo proor
Hawk we're taught that in school in the
freshman
year that just because a thing follows
another thing doesn't mean the first
thing caused
it and so just because I'm white or male
or from
Louisiana it doesn't follow necessarily
that I'm
racist I'm not denying that many people
are
and that has a long history in there of
that that certainly could be discussed
but to then turn it around and lay it on
the
student that you are implicitly
racist because you
exist that is what I call flawed
reasoning and that's what I object to in
that line of
teaching that's what I'm wondering your
sense where does reasoning apply those
kind of faulty elements of an argument
when does that get challenged because
you can't do it in the US Army anymore
they've got a four-star general up there
telling you that this is the truth I
don't know about your military
experience I was in the Marines and the
Army and the
Navy and none of them would have
tolerated that sort of in what they
would see in subordination so that is
being taught in our nation and what
we're objecting to are some aspects of
it thank you representative board for
your question um through our work uh in
this area and specifically within the
past 12 months we have
reviewed dozens and dozens of different
curriculum throughout the state we have
talked to you know probably close to a
hundred different Educators we have read
I want to say a pile of books along
these lines that are talking about
really important issues of race and
racism in our country and how they are
manifested and nothing that we have read
or
discussed
um makes the assertion that you are
describing with regards to somebody
being inherently racist um it's they
what they are encouraging is a critical
look at the issues of race in our
society they are encouraging people to
to to consider what impact historical
events have on what is happening in our
society currently um and those are the
type again of conversations that I be
believe are being chilled by the
existing law and that chill would only
be spread by HB 13313 and its expansion
of the existing law to the university
system representative
lakas
um the law my understanding my reading
of the
law what's
actually
um
the conversation that just happened was
specifically saying that you can't teach
that one race is inherently Superior
inferior whatever or
sex because of those physical properties
so I don't see I don't understand I'm
hoping you can explain to me how
something that says that you can't make
those assertions then becomes we can't
talk about those things especially when
the law says these things can be
discussed there's a big difference
between talking about racism and people
who are racist and places where racism
shows up Etc and teaching that because
you're white you're racist those are two
completely different things so I'm not
sure what do we have to do to make
clear
that that what is against the law is
teaching that you're white therefore
you're racist as opposed to okay let's
look at racism and because it does exist
in this country but that's very
different to say racism exists in this
country and these are incidents and
these are harms that are caused and all
these great discussions is very
different than saying you're white
you're racist thank you representative I
think you bring up a a really important
issue and it's one that has been raised
by by other representatives in the
course of this discussion I think the
concern and what we're seeing with the
existing law is that you know it's these
these supposed distinctions that are
being made between you know
discussing um you know what has has
happened historically versus having you
know advocating versus instructing
versus Etc um these these distinctions
as in the fluidity of the classroom in
an in an exchange that a teacher is
having with the class are really almost
impossible to parse and I think that's
why we're seeing the conduct of teachers
and what the way that teachers are are
willing and able um uh to are are
needing to um amend their curriculum
because they're afraid to getting
anywhere close to the line um that they
are are trying to figure out that the
law might me what might be meant in the
law um and so you know when you when you
you talk to say it's okay to discuss
these things well is it okay to discuss
why in our country's uh history for
example only a single African-American
has ever been elected president of the
United States and no woman ever has is
that okay to discuss in the course of
the classroom under this concept can you
teach about proven facts that racial and
other un unconscious biases have shut
the doors of opportunity for many people
in our country and continue to do so
today you know what is the line between
instructing that And discussing that um
I think it's impossible and it is
increasingly difficult for teachers to
be able to try to parse what that line
might mean especially when their jobs
are potentially on the line because of
threat and Sh sanctions and threaten um
lawsuits uh so I think that that the
distinction that the law is is asking
teachers to make in the course of a
fluid classroom is really quite
impossible in practice and that's why we
seeing the existing
sh any further questions
M thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question um because teachers are
regularly being evaluated for their
continual
employment doesn't this bill because of
its vagueness leave open to subjective
interpretation by the evaluator whether
bill is being
violated thank you representative I
think um you bring up a very important
point because again because the bills
the the concepts in the bill about what
is banned are so vague uh that they all
not only uh leave it open to the subject
interpretation of whomever might be
evaluating whether it's a teacher or in
case of 1313 a professor in the
University system but it leaves it up to
every single individual student in that
classroom to make that evaluation and
then decide whether or not they're going
to file a lawsuit against that um that
individual um so yes I think that's the
the the the the subjectivity involved in
determining what is in fact a violation
of this law is a huge part of of why the
vagueness is his problem um and why
quite frankly that that that that we
that the Supreme Court has held vague
laws to be unconstitutional in this
regard
luno thank thank you very much Mr chair
and first off my apologies to
representative laett I'm sorry to
interrupted you earlier this afternoon
um and um and thank you for taking my
question Miss chaffy um it really sort
of goes to um I it sort of follows on
what representative Mullen was uh was
was leading on earlier where um where
where where this bill um um obviously
does not amend the four parts a c and d
and 19340 part one um and I think a lot
of our discussion has centered around a
b and c but in Reading D I was wondering
if if if you could um provide some some
thoughts on on what what D is is going
after here and
um I'm sorry could you provide me with
the citation so it's um
it's it's 19340 which is the the
prohibition on teaching discrimination
is the title of the
section and I don't know if it may be
maybe here well no it wouldn't be in
here because it's not updated enough
um but but I can I can read it so it it
begins with um with part two of the
bill um and I'll just read the last part
of it attending a and no student
attending a public postsecondary
educational institution shall be taught
instructed inculcated or compelled to
express belief in or support for any one
or more of the following and of the
following is an a a b a c and a D and
the D reads that people of one age sex
gender identity sexual orientation race
Creed color marital status familial
status mental or physical disability
religion or national origin cannot and
should not attempt to treat others
without regard to age sex gender
identity sexual orientation race Creed
color marital status FAL status mental
physical disability religion natural
origin so the
um I'm trying to understand how how how
this reads so um not inated or compelled
to express belief in or support
for I'm sort of just you know editing um
um support
for that people of one age and all that
cannot and should not attempt to treat
others without regard to all those same
conditions I I think that I I think that
you are right to be be confused if that
is what you are um that is what you are
expressing um you know I think it's it's
very unclear you know what what that
that provision section d means um what
does it mean to treat a person without
respect to age race sex or disability
Etc um I think in in
instances I think it even
creates if I'm reading this
correctly a double negative in in the
sentence right right and so you have you
have a double negative here that further
confuses what is what is um what is
meant uh by that particular
prohibition um and so I I think that's
that is part of the problem
representative is is the confusion that
is sewn by the lack of clarity in the
language what is that provision trying
to get to um and I'd be happy to also um
if it's helpful to the committee send
the committee a copy we get into this in
Greater detail in our filing our
complaints um with regards to the
underlying law and we go through each
specific concept there um I I I wish
that our legal director Jill biset could
have been with you here today
unfortunately he tested Co POS POS
yesterday so I am here uh pin shining
today but I'd be happy to provide you
with a copy of the of the brief that
really does go through these Concepts
individually but the the gist of of what
you will read is is sort of confirming
representative I think what you're what
you're referring to which is it's
incredibly confusing and very difficult
to tell what the law is intending to be
it terrific um Devon I think that would
be that would be a tremendous help to
the committee especially as as this
committee looks at at the extension of
the law to to include public um
institutions of higher education and and
then finally this committee is lucky to
have have um Gillis or you any time uh
here to testify so thank you very much
thank you are there any further
questions uh resident
Woodcock ah good I know green with gold
and red with st but thank you
um here somewhere behind the hidden
behind the the head the
hello uh thank you so much for coming U
I've been listening I listened uh
attentively and I was get lost with
represent for I thinking about the whole
the problem between correlation
causation as he was speaking but uh as I
started to think about this from uh
going back into the classroom as an
instructor and going back into the
classroom of 12 years of college
instructor I would wonder how
how based on this law you would present
the underlying causes in the topic of
the glass
ceiling how could you possibly instruct
in that that with that topic based on
this law I think that's representative
Co I think you
present a very a very good question you
know you know issues like the like the
concept of of the glass ceiling of I
think the questions there have been a
number of questions questions that have
been raised um and representative wcky
might do a better job than I do of just
quickly detailing what theing oh
probably not you can go ahead I wouldn't
be a violation um per perhaps we could
that's really not part of this bill um I
think you're addressing what's in
current law now so I was talking let me
clarify represent thank you for my
buying here uh at the postsecondary
level was this was this law I was
talking that's what I meant the
postsecondary level
yes representative those are exactly the
type of questions that we are receiving
from Educators is how do I talk about
even these most basic concepts um
associated with um whether it be racism
or sexism whether it be historically or
as currently exists in our society how
do we talk about these basic concepts um
under the current law and and then I
think you the concerns that we've heard
from secondary uh Educators about what
would this mean if it were to apply in
the classroom uh at at a second
as well I'm sorry postc
level thank you very much thank you um
is uh thank you very much for your
testimony thank you um is um Megan
Tuttle still
here
yeah maybe you can fill out a card when
you're finished
yes
can you hear me all right
okay thank you Mr chairman uh members of
the committee uh for the record Brian
Hawkins I'm here today representing uh
Nea New Hampshire um and I'll submit a
card
uh okay okay great um
and uh I I will not repeat I'm going to
hand in some written testimony from um
our president Megan Tuttle so I won't
read that but I will do a summary and
and uh also would Echo a lot of the
things that uh Miss chaffy said
earlier here to express Nea New
Hampshire's opposition to House Bill
1313 this legislation appears to add
public postsecondary institutions to law
passed in House Bill 2 having to do with
ban Concepts now it's no secret that we
strongly disagree with the laws passage
and also strongly opposed to further
expanding it to include public higher
education institutions of our state
there's going to be other legislation
that's going to come forward later in
the session um on the current law itself
so rather than get into the uh
nitty-gritty of the of the law that was
already passed and its Merit
um um I just want to summarize a couple
points uh the band Concepts language
that is being proposed has already as
Miss chaffy indicated created a chill
that effectively prevents teachers from
doing what Society needs them to do and
that's teach our students uh the laws
resulted in the curbing of essential
teaching practices um such as Competency
Based learning critical thinking um but
um uh why so why would we want to expand
this uh law into uh higher
education um and these circumstances
mainly stem from the ban Concepts laws
ambiguous vague language along with the
Steep consequences that can result from
running a fou of it the vagueness uh has
resulted in the law becoming the subject
of two Federal
lawsuits um and so it would be premature
for us uh to be expanding that until
we've gotten some further
uh guidance from from from uh from the
courts um also Educators across the
state are still grappling with how to
follow this law we have asked uh for
specific guidance and two letters to
both the attorney general and the
Department of
Education um questions that we've heard
from our members um uh so that they can
follow the law because we want to follow
the law um and th those have gone un
unanswered um so with all of this
unsettled and people still grappling
with how to comply with the law it seems
premature to go ahead and expand it
um our students uh deserve the freedom
to learn they deserve to be part of an
education that helps learn from the
mistakes of our past so they're better
prepared to succeed and um so to inhibit
New Hampshire's public colleges and
University faculty and staff from um
engaging in these kinds of discussions
to help uh teach and challenge students
to use this knowledge uh to form their
own opinions um it's a disservice to
them and to the state of New Hampshire
and so we would respectfully ask that
you find House Bill 1313 and expedient
to legislate thank you and um if you
want to hand in the written testimony
that would be fine you can pass that to
our clerk any questions
seen none thank you very
much and uh next on the docket is uh
Shannon Reed from the community college
system good
afternoon for the record my name is
Shannon Reed I am director of government
Affairs for the community college system
of New Hampshire thank thank you for the
opportunity to provide testimony on
House Bill
1313 relative to rights to freedom from
discrimination in higher education
respectfully ccsnh has significant
concerns about this bill first with
respect to section one the community
college system is already considered an
employer under RSA
354a so it is not clear to us why
section one of the bill is necessary it
it seems redundant with respect to
section two the construction of the
section is unusual as it puts language
governing the community college system
into RSA 193 which pertains generally to
pupils in New Hampshire's Elementary and
secondary schools nonetheless the
substance of the section appears to be
the inclusion of public post-secondary
education in the prohibitions on
teaching discrimination set forth in RSA
19340 it's unclear to us how the
inclusion of public postsecondary
education in those prohibitions he's
supposed to exist side by side with the
existing language in RSA 354 a29 which
says nothing in this subdivision shall
be construed to limit the academic
freedom of Faculty members of the
University system of New Hampshire and
the community college system of New
Hampshire to conduct research publish
lecture or teach in the academic setting
end quote is it to be the case that
nothing in one subdivision shall be
construed to limit that academic freedom
freedom but House Bill 1313 plac this
language in a different subdivision that
does limit it we're not sure what that's
supposed to mean in
practice similarly despite the intent of
the bill to include public
post-secondary education in those
prohibitions set forth in
19340 the term educator in Roman five of
that section remains defined in the K
through2 context as for the purposes of
this section educator means a profession
employee of any school district whose
position requires certification by the
state board pursuant to RSA
18939 administrators Specialists and
teachers are included within the
definition of this term end quote
College faculty did not fall under this
definition the violation provision in
Roman four refers to sanction by the
State Board of Education which does not
oversee College faculty this again
points to the overall construction of
hasel
13113 appearing somewhat convoluted and
of unclear
applicability that said the general
intent to include public post-secondary
education under
19340 would seem to raise contradictions
with widely accepted tenants of academic
freedom of college and University
faculty regardless of which way one
leans on the concept the ambiguities
themselves are going to be very
problematic hpel 13313 would introduce
competing Provisions in New Hampshire
law and add to questions about the
relationship of this language with con
institutional protections we're aware
the divisive concept's language passed
with respect to K through2 education is
already the subject of federal lawsuits
that in part challenge the new language
on issues of lack of clarity this would
seem only more problematic with respect
to postsecondary education and the
freedoms that are historically part of
the college
environment we are very interested in
not curbing the free flow of ideas that
should characterize post-secondary
education we believe our faculty
encourage open and critical thinking we
are not aware of any assertions that
they have used their role to compel
belief in or support for particular
agendas or that students have been
denied exposure to the marketplace of
ideas on the contrary we believe the
general fear is that legislation like
hille 1313 would in fact lead to
constraints on the free flow of ideas we
would hope that the legislature not take
a step that will lead to uncertainty and
conflict over academic freedom that
students and faculty Both Deserve and to
which they have a right thank you happy
to take any questions thank you any
questions for Miss
Reed see none thank you very
much uh next is Mr
Cronin uh good afternoon again Mr
chairman and members of the committee
Tom Cronin director of government
relations for the University system
thank you for having us in on house
bill3 1413 um I'll keep my testimony
brief um we are largely in agreement
with many of the all of the points I
think that uh Miss Reed just laid out on
behalf of the community college system
uh with relation to the construction of
the the legislation uh again agreed uh
section one of the bill seems
unnecessary uh we believe usnh as well
as ccsnh uh already fall under the
definition of Quasi public entities um
we believe we are a covered employer we
accept we are a covered employer
um section two of the bill uh adds
postsecondary language to RSA 193 um as
you all are well aware that is the
section of Statute governing Public
Schools higher education is governed
elsewhere in statute uh I think Miss
Reed did a fantastic job of laying out
the inconsistencies that follow as a
result and then third um as you all know
again when the legislature enacted the
freedom from discrimination law they
codified a clear provision protecting
academic freedom um I'll read it one
more time time nothing in this
subdivision shall be construed to limit
the academic freedom of Faculty members
of the University system of New
Hampshire and the community college
system of New Hampshire to conduct
research publish lecture or teach in the
academic setting um it's unclear because
that uh protection sits in the
commission on human rights section of
law again so how it all necessarily fits
together here is I think incredibly
unclear but regardless I think
that lack of clarity and what is likely
it seems to be the intent based on the
prime sponsor's
testimony is to have just a clear
chilling effect on classroom instruction
uh there's no doubt that passing this
law will lead to a proliferation of
lawsuits against the state's colleges
and universities um from students who
feel as though they have been assigned
or are in some way wronged by something
an academic or a professor or teacher
says to them um that I think is our
biggest concern uh it does not seem to
be a productive step forward um in how
we ensure academic freedom free speech
on our campuses uh and the free exchange
of ideas so maybe with that I'll stop
and would of course be happy to take any
questions thank you any questions for Mr
Cronin repr
Tanner thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr K for taking my question um going
back to our first speaker about how uh
College professors um you know say you
know I have this Theory or I have this
belief and uh you have to regurgitate it
to me or not get an A you you know
you'll get a lower grade or you know uh
there's only one way to to deal with
this subject and and so if you take my
class that's how you do it okay um seems
like it's more pedagogy than um content
that we're talking about here but I was
wondering if the university system has a
way for students that are caught in that
situation that that feel as though
they've been unduly discriminated
against um how they uh can have recourse
of course thank you for the question and
that actually gives me an opportunity
maybe to speak to I
think what seems to be a pervasive
thought in this that faculty members at
the University and other ways other
places are are forcing an ideology on
students I mean we've heard this before
of course uh our Administration our
faculty are committed to a set of
ethical principles in their work um
there it is the American Association of
University professors they have a
detailed uh ethics manual that speaks to
a range of topics but one of them really
is this and if I could just read uh a
quickish excer uh indoctrination occurs
when instructors dogmatically insist on
the truth of such propositions by
refusing to Accord their students the
opportunity to contest them
indoctrination occurs when instructors
assert such propositions and ways that
prevent students from expressing
disagreement vigorously to assert a
proposition or Viewpoint however
controversial is to engage in
argumentation and discussion an
engagement that lies at the core of
academic freedom such engagement is
essential if students are to acquire
skills of critical Independence the
essence of higher education does not lie
in the passive transmission of knowledge
but in the inculcation of a mature
independence of mind and I think that
really gets to your point that that is
that is the the code of ethics that our
faculty uh commit to live by in the
event that a student feels like he or
she is is being graded unfairly uh is
being treated poorly in a class
certainly there are processes to uh make
complaints to file appeals on grading
Etc that would in in theory surface
issues like that that would lead to
conversations uh within if if it gets to
that stage a disciplinary context um for
a faculty member who is clearly acting
outside of that well defined and agreed
upon code of
effs thank you anything further if not
thank you very much for testifying again
and the final speaker we have listed is
Louise
Spencer I just have to pull up something
here um hi thank you Mr Vice chair for
taking my testimony and um to all the
committee members here today my name is
Louise Spencer I'm co-founder of an all
volunteer Grassroots advocacy group
called The Kent Street
Coalition um and although um I would
that most of the members of our group
would agree with my comments here today
uh I speak on my own behalf um
so many people who speak in favor of
this legislation and the addition to it
quote Martin Luther King Jr's I Have a
Dream speech with the um idea that we've
already achieved that goal and it's your
right to make that argument but many
disagree that we have achieved a state
where we are not judged by the color of
our skin or our sex or our gender or our
disabilities and that's kind of the
point really that we disagree and we can
have discussions and we can argue and
that's what this bill would shut down is
that very discussion about where we are
with race relations in this country and
where we are with uh sexual equality and
gender equality
um all across the board all the
categories that are um spoken to I'm not
sure why I'm so nervous today speaking
usually I'm not but I'm feeling nervous
perhaps because I feel so passionately
about this bill and one of the greatest
things I achieved out of my college
education was the ability to have these
very difficult and painful discussions
at
times that really is the best of what a
college education can offer I do not
need to agree with my professor nor does
my professor need to agree with me the
point is that we engage in discussion
and we do it with
respect that's the value of a secondary
postsecondary
education um
I would just like to read the full quote
U Miss
chii uh gave part of it but I'd like to
read a full quote from do Dr Martin
Luther King it says um whites it must
frankly be said are not putting in a
similar mass effort to re-educate
themselves out of their racial ignorance
it is an aspect of their sense of
superiority that white people of America
believe that they have so little to
learn the reality of substantial
investment to assist Negroes into the
20th century adjusting to negro
neighbors and genuine integration is
still a nightmare for all too many white
Americans these are the deepest causes
for contemporary abrasions between the
races loose and easy language about
equality resonant resolutions about
Brotherhood uh resonant resolutions
about Brotherhood fall pleasantly on the
ear but for the Negro there is a
credibility gap he cannot Overlook he
remembers that with each modest Advance
the white population promptly raises the
argument that the Negro has come far
enough each step forward accents an
everpresent tendency to backlash that
was remarks delivered by Martin Luther
King Jr in
1967 now Les we doubt that he might
still hold those beliefs today or
similar beliefs his daughter Bernie King
has made very clear that she finds these
bills that are anti-crt and that attempt
to shut down the discussions of ongoing
racial institutional discrimination and
bias in our country which is really um
what CRT attempts to address it's not
about individuals being racist it's
about
institutions um and she has said that
she quite frankly finds it insulting
that the words of her father are used to
support this sort of
legislation and that her father's Works
need to be looked at
holistically again we can discuss and
argue those points but it raises the
question if Martin Luther King Jr were
still alive today and this bill were
passed and he were invited to speak as a
guest lecturer a professor at UNH with
he be subjected to the sanctions of this
bill and I think the answer to that
question is yes so thank you very much
and I will take questions thank you any
questions for Miss Spencer see none okay
representative
luno thank you very much Miss Spencer
for for being with us this afternoon and
um and when um when you were just sort
of laying this out it reminded me of
something that I heard heard actually
this morning on on NPR while I was
driving in here you may have heard the
same the same thing but uh they were
talking the the um the the story was was
basically about a um and there is a
question that's G come into this I
promise but um
but but um um it it was actually it was
very interesting it's about the Hubble
telescope which uh you know has been up
there a while it's been recently uh um
replaced by by a new launch but anyway
every year for about the last 25 or so
years that the hubbles telescope has
been in in operation NASA receives about
1100 applications to run experiments on
the Hubble and they come from
universities all across you know
certainly the United States but across
the globe and um and anyway somebody a
few years ago asked GE can you give us
an idea is to the number of applications
that come from from male principal
investigators versus female principal
investigators and ones that are approved
anyway they hadn't been they've been
collecting the information but they
never analyzed that so they were able to
um go back and inferring actually they
didn't collect the the gender
information but they uh they did have
the names and they were Bas basically
inferring based on names and they found
consistently for every year and this is
these are academic institutions
approximately a six or 7% biased towards
male scientists versus female scientists
who are submitting these applications so
recently uh they made a change and they
hid the names of the principal
investigators and guess what the number
of female principal investigators
actually ex receiving applications
actually went up and it happened in year
one and it was dramatic and my question
Mr chair
is how
would policies like this interfere with
with with um with the ability to make
change in society to to try to level the
playing field for um for and I'm just
picking male and female but obviously
other please reply quickly because I
think we're strained a little from uh
the actual bill itself and we are a
little bit behind schedu specifically
for higher education yeah I think it
impacts second postsecondary education
particularly because that's where grants
and other issues are made and um are um
have the most relevance um I think you
also see it with for example UNH with
they have a public health program um
they have um there's a law school uh
looking at issues can we ever make take
into account differences of
experiences um based on a person's um
you know whe their sex their
disabilities uh can we sort for that to
make sure that we are providing equal
opportunities for all um again that
might sometimes make people
uncomfortable to realize that that's
been done in the past and um that there
has been discrimination in the past and
there could be ongoing discrimination
but we are better when we um learn from
that and and try to correct for it
rather than try to argue that it doesn't
exist thank you very much l and I think
that
ends the uh testimony on this bill and
we will move um on to to House Bill
1685 and I see representative uh Mooney
here and uh sorry that uh we're a little
bit behind schedule for you no problem
Mr chairman in fact I'm very grateful
that everybody who came to testify today
and be heard has been given that
opportunity despite a time lag so I'm
happy to
wait I do have testimony which I uh gave
to the clerk prior to the last bill
which will be distributed it's my
written testimony as well as a proposed
amendment that I have to House Bill uh
685 when you're
ready yes go ahead okay thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is Moren money I'm a
state representative from the town of
marac in Hillsboro County District
number 21 I hope there's some joy in
seeing me today as the last Prime
sponsor to introduce a bill to all of
you this afternoon I'm in support of
House Bill 1685 also the prime sponsor
which is an act establishing a school
facility planning and development
program in the Department of Education
this bill would add a new section to the
school money section which is RSA
198 the new section would create a
school facility planning and development
program for both and I emphasize that
word both school districts and chartered
Public
Schools the program shall be managed by
the school safety and facility
management Bureau of the New Hampshire
Department of Education whose mission is
very clearly stated on its website in
fact I cut and pasted it within my
testimony in italics I won't read it for
you now but you'll see just upon
glancing that the school safety and
facility management Bureau overseas
facilities building needs and the
like the program shall establish a
revolving fund to a help school
districts and chartered public schools
with Planning and Development expenses
related to facility Improvement projects
and B administer a loan program for
school districts and chartered public
schools to support long-term school
facility plans the bill specifically
spells out the Loan program very clearly
in sections B numbers one through four
including eligible planning costs scope
and amount of loans and
prioritizing
applicants the final section of the bill
places reference of this new program
into the State Treasury and state
accounts found found in RSA 6 colon
12 Roman
1B please know I have an amendment to
propose to all of you correcting just
two small what I find typos within the
bill uh it's amendment number
2022 hyen
03h to correct uh those typos in line 17
and 19 and to do my best to uh conserve
on paper my amendment is on the back
side of my written testimony you'll see
on line uh
17 there is
uh a better way for that to be
worded so that would then uh instead of
reading the loan should cover costs
which are not eligible for funding via
it would simply read the loan should
cover costs which are not funded by
existing state and federal
programs and the second part of my
proposed amendment uh takes out an extra
word there in line number 19 with that I
am going to conclude my testimony I know
the logistics of such uh will be
testified on by uh individuals who make
remarks uh Beyond me and so for that i'
bring that up I conclude my testimony I
want to thank you all certainly for
listening your time today and always and
your service to the state in New
Hampshire thank you Mr chairman thank
thank you very much just uh we have uh
three people and get the attention of
the committee here we have the option
here of taking several others right now
to testify we could get Amy Clark from
the Department offering technical
assistance on the bill if we so desire
to hear that before we hear the
others any interest she's here she's
here could I weigh in on that as well or
if yes go ahead my SU just is to have
Amy Clark testify after me uh that's
what I was trying to get Bo so we are
going to invite Amy are you sitting here
yeah I saw you behind there would you
please come forward and and uh if there
are questions this this is the
individual from the Department you
should ask your questions on this
Bill thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee thank you very
much welcome to the education
committee thank you uh welcome or thank
you for having me um I appreciate your
time uh and for the record my name is
Amy Clark and I am the administrator for
the school safety and facility
management Bureau at the Department of
Education thank you now are there any
questions to because she signed up for
technical assistance on this bill uh
reading through the bill are there any
questions from the committee on
this yes represent um thanks very much
Mr chair thanks very much Miss Clark I
know just recently um we um uh put
forward legislation I think it probably
hopefully made its uh way through
through the process that um that
established a um uh an application um or
process for the Department to withdraw
funds or to apply for funds from the
infr the infrastructure from the
infrastructure fund to be used for um
for engineering assessment and um and
project
prioritization um I guess does is would
would this um proposal be consistent
with that type of um uh effort going
forward or is it some sort of parallel
um you know planning effort that uh
would be funded and districts would take
up independently um probably the
probably two separate things so um I
believe what you're referring to is the
facility assessment the goal it would be
for the state to assess school
facilities um all public schools charg
schools obviously included uh in that
and so that gives the schools um and the
state an an opportunity to plan better
of what to do with funds um and the
state of our schools right but I think
the intent of this bill really is to um
say a school is ready to do something
um but the application process isn't
something that you can just do overnight
um apply for building Aid you really
have to put a lot of planning involved
so you have to decide whether it's um
makes sense to just continue on without
rebuilding or maybe you want to do a
renovation maybe you want to do an
addition what are your educational needs
in that building and how are they not
being met so I think that this really is
to focus on a project specific versus
the assessment of but they certainly
dovea
sure on on a follow up on that Mr chair
doesn't doesn't the existing um uh
application process support both
planning projects as well as um the
capital you know project as
well the infrastructure fund has we
develop you if you don't mind yeah yeah
yeah um there there was $2 million
allocated this previous B for this bium
of which there's another million dollars
which has been added in so there's the
money which carried forward and so we're
talking about roughly around three a
little over $3
million we also within the legislation
that represented ly was speaking to and
I'm a little confused on this myself is
that we're driving home for a 10year
plan in terms of our capital projects to
get on that list after we do the
assessment this uh legislation is
talking about facility Improvement
projects including but not Li lied to
projects eligible for school building
Aid I believe the legislation that we
just passed said in order to get on that
to get be eligible for building Aid
you're going to have to be on that on
that
list now here's something is saying
maybe you don't have to be on that
list so I I think the two separate
things would be that the public school
infrastructure fund that $3.3 million is
I think the goal would be to create A
ranked a list of the school facilities
and how they're doing and if you're
interested in implying from building Aid
one of those things may be that you have
to be uh assessed through that program
prior to applying so that we really have
an understanding of um what that
building already the condition of that
building so that people don't waste
their time applying for that but I think
what this is trying to do is um help
districts that may not have those
resources whether they be Public School
District or public um Charter Schools
put together an application by hiring an
architect um doing all that planning
that is involved in putting together a
building aid application um so this is
like the um this is the state revolving
fund that would assist a school district
in putting together that application
once they decide that that's what they
want to move forward with whereas the
rank the public school infrastructure
fund that
is really to the picture of the state
and all the school facilities in their
condition um whether they're going to
build or not would be up to the school
district I'm sort of halfway there with
you um my concern I guess is
that when you're on the list and you
you're you're you're then going forward
with your
application if your application awarded
do you get reimbursed for the cost
associated with putting that application
together I would say yes
yes you get reimbursed from the school
building aid appliation funds that you
receed not from I a fund such as this
cor correct although this is a loan
program so it wouldn't be a grant
program so if if you were granted money
through another program let's say the
Essa or arp uh funds then that money
would not be eligible because that was
money given to the school district so
that would be ineligible but money from
a loan program would be eligible because
it would just be like a a school
district going to their own private bank
and getting uh funds for their project
too um so this money in my view this
money would be eligible for school
building Aid at least the law doesn't
currently prohibit um any kind of Loan
program money being eligible for
building Aid um building Aid is never
eligible for interest payments anyway
it's really just the principal amount so
it doesn't really even matter that this
is interest free or not interest
free I have one other question for the
committee and then I'll let now the
school building
authority which is tasked with bonding
and all
that um is there any involvement with a
school building authority with this fund
and the allocation X number of dollars
for um I don't I don't see that listed
anywhere this doesn't look like this is
um compl this is not really linked to
building Aid now this is a um it gives
an example that you could use you could
plan a project and then it doesn't
Prelude you from applying for building
aid but this this state revolving fund
um also would include it says in here
that it would include any any projects
to help with that Planning and
Development it's a way to help school
districts that can't come up with their
Planning and Development costs to put
together a good plan prior to either
moving forward with their plan on their
own local dollars or applying to school
building
Aid are there further questions
yesah thank you and thank you for taking
my question um I noticed uh it seems
like people are talking definitely
emphasizing Charter School part of it
was Charter Schools not involved in this
before uh and are now being implemented
with the building Aid is that is that my
understanding there is another bill I am
aware that there's another bill to um
include them in school building Aid
right now charter schools are not
eligible for school building Aid uh and
so right now Charter Schools can't apply
for building aid but if that bill passes
then they would be eligible for build
aid but to keep in mind this isn't
specific to Charter Schools it would be
for all school districts and there are a
lot of um school districts that struggle
to put together a building aid
application because it takes a lot of
planning money that they don't have
access
to yes you so what happens to this bill
if the if the other one doesn't pass or
vice versa so if the other one doesn't
so let's say this bill passes but the
other one passes that specifically
includes charter schools in school
building Aid Public School District
could still use the state revolving fund
the way it's written it's just for all
public schools um to use this fund and I
I believe that representative Mooney
included that in our testimony um but if
the other one passes then obviously
Charter Schools could tap into the state
revolving fund as
well and actually I I'm sorry I I think
I did misspeak or mislead anyway I keep
in mind that this is not only for but
building Aid regardless if that bill
passes Charter Schools could still use
the state revolving fund I I I don't
think I clearly said that before so
Charter Schools could still use this
even if they're not eligible for
building Aid at least the way it's
written because this is not does not
require schools to use this money to
apply for building
Aid you have a follow question
yes um so for the the uh ranked uh the
ranking uh based on your uh based on the
applications about the conditions of the
program how does that what criteria do
you use for the ranking are are all
schools and and Charter Schools
considered um let's say they they have a
school that's a hundred years old and
they need you know the they have Steam
Heat so there's no ventilation um and
they're a public Elementary School uh
how are they ranked against for example
char schol school that wants to open in
a strip mall that uh the strip mall has
uh poor ventilation as well I mean how
do you how do you make those
determinations is there any priority set
um so if a public if a charter school
was eligible Public Charter School was
eligible for building Aid There's no
distinction in the law that would judge
them any differently than an elementary
school or not but but to answer your
question that franking criteria is based
on a lot of things but one of them is um
safety issues um
condition assessment of the school
overcrowding um Ada correcting Ada
issues any kind of life safety issues um
also included in there there are um
percent eligible for free and reduced
lunch um costs so there are some things
that um if public charger schools become
eligible for Aid that that might be a
little bit more difficult to calculate
um yeah there's some other criteria as
well further questions yes
representative
Mullen thank you Mr chair and thank you
uh Amy for taking my question I I just
want to make sure that I understand
what's happening here so this bill
establishes the program and a revolving
Loan Fund but it doesn't appropriate any
money for it nor does it give us any
indication of where the money might be
coming from or how much money
might be needed in that fund am I
correct in that correct that's a very
very good point um in here at the bottom
it talks about um establishing a fund so
that fund would need to be established
that there's no funding source that I'm
aware of nor is there any indication
again that I'm aware of of how much
money the legislature wants to put in
there whether it be enough to cover four
four Planning and Development projects
or 10 or 50 and and a follow to that Mr
chair if you're okay with that and so do
you have an understanding of how much I
mean it says up to
$100,000 loan per and that it's Net Zero
because I would assume the charter or
the district is meant to pay it back to
the fund but do you have any sense of
knowing what kinds of building needs and
projects are out there what kind of
startup money would be need needed for
this to happen uh that's very good
question it's hard to say how how many
schools might take advantage of that but
just to give you an example um building
Aid um occurs in a bium cycle those um
they call them letters of intent school
districts have to let um the Department
of Education know that they're
interested in applying for building Aid
uh again charter schools are not
currently eligible but of the other
Public Schools we just received 28
applications totaling
$650 Million worth of projects over the
next two years the building Aid portion
of that is about 250 million um but keep
in mind that's 28 projects so to more to
answer your question it was 28 projects
over the course of two years it's 14
projects a year if they were all seeking
$100,000 then here you have $1.4 million
um but that's not to that's not to say
that all those schol would need to find
there are many schools that would not
that would that don't need access to
this money and I imagine there' be some
kind of there's some rul Mak Authority
in here that perhaps that rul making
Authority would have to adjust based on
how much the legislature the legislature
gives 1.4 million then the rules might
not have to establish where that money
goes but if that funding is a lot less
then those rules might need to address
issues thank you further questions
representative Porter
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I don't know much
about the uh physical condition of the
charter schools that we have in the
state now but I don't are there many
that have their own buildings that would
be wanting building Aid or you know like
what percentage of our Charter Schools
do you think might need this a
and that'll be the end of my question
yeah that's also a good question
unfortunately I don't have that data in
front of me I do have that in the office
um but right now a lot majority of our
Charter Schools lease um but at the same
time the longer a charter school is
established they may be looking we
certainly have charter schools that do
own their own buildings uh and keep in
mind there's a a program that dovet
Tales building Aid called lease Aid um
that's available for charter schools and
I don't know how much that drives a
charter to school to say we're going to
continue to lease because we have access
to lease a versus we're thinking about
building and if we build then we're long
going to have lease Aid I don't know the
answers to those questions but um what I
could provide the committee if You' like
is um a list of how many Charter Schools
own their own buildings and how many
schools need have
data representative Porter uh I see Matt
Southerton here director of the charter
school group maybe he might have that
answer for you when he speaks further
questions for rep
Amy
Clark promoting
me I thought that
go well thank you very much Amy and Are
You Gonna State for the remainder of
this in case another sure I'll be
available thank you very much Matt
Southerton are you
available
good afternoon Mr chairman
Matton choking ha polities uh I've
worked with New Hampshire charter
schools for about 20 years um I wanted
to make my comments brief because I know
that you've all been here for a long
time
today uh when I saw this bill I was
really excited because I know that we
have a number of uh small school
districts and a number of small charter
schools that could uh really use prr
like this I think it would be good
public policy uh when I read this
bill it struck me as a tool that
districts and Charter Schools could use
and a program that the department could
use to
facilitate assisting charter schools and
districts to access the experts that
they need to help to help them
understand whether a project is good or
not for them right uh these small
schools and these districts just frankly
do not have the expertise or the funding
necessary to um be able to assess these
whether some of these uh improvements
are whether it makes sense for them
right so I I am supportive of this
project and uh we're supportive of this
point and I'd be happy to take any
questions I heard the one about how many
charter schools um actually own their
own building I believe it's four in New
Hampshire that'd be SE Co Charter School
ledard charter school Founders in micro
Society
Charo okay are there any questions for
Matt
Southerton Matt do you have any idea
what the condition of those four
facilities look like bear middle and
what they are uh they are in uh pretty
good condition they um I don't think
that at this time they'd actually take
advantage of this program but I know
that a number of charter schools that
that that are very interested I spoke
with a number of Charter School
directors around the state I think that
they're supportive of this bill and they
would like to have been here however due
to staffing issues they weren't able to
attend this
session other further
questions thank you very
much
Bill Phillips National Alliance for
public uh CH uh Charter
Schools Mr chair my apologies I saw you
reading that card so my handwriting is
not so hot no it looks very all right
it's very legible all right
yeah yeah obviously had zayer blower a
Palmer methods for learning how to write
and
print uh I'm old enough
yes anyway I'm Bill Phillips I'm with
the National Alliance for public charter
schools um first I'd like to thank
representative Mooney for introducing
this bill and I actually also like to
thank the committee for allowing me to
speak
um you know between the representative
and between Miss Clark I think they've
explained what the bill does I'll be
happy to take questions on that I what
I'd like to do is just briefly discuss
the two parts of the bill uh that we in
particular like we obviously support
this this bill uh I think the way you
know if you were to describe the
building aid process uh I'll call it
appropriately
arduous um it frequently requires exper
uh expertise engineering construction
legal
financing um the issue is that those are
costs that I think a lot of uh districts
not a lot of uh I think lower resource
districts and most Charter Schools
cannot
afford the relevance of that is if you
are involved in the application process
uh for building Aid uh the ability to
pay for expertise gives you a
competitive advantage and what I like
about this bill here is it it allows the
uh previously mentioned the districts
that don't have as much money and the
charter schools to actually pay for
expertise that allows them to fill out
the application in a way that allows
them to be competitive that's one part
that we obviously like the other part
that I that I like is I actually think
this bill is is useful um in this case
I'm speaking directly to the Charter
School issue I believe it's useful to
the Charter Schools um in a couple ways
one say you're doing a project I know
there's a building Aid bill
out there obviously I hope you support
that but let's just take that to the
side for a second say you had a a
project that just it wasn't um it wasn't
appropriate for building a it was it was
you know just a couple hundred thousand
dollars uh maybe you know say you had a
drainage issue or something like that
you still need expertise and you're
still GNA go out for private
financing a lot of our Charter Schools
would have a hard time accessing the
expertise they need just to get private
private financing so this bill if it was
the pass I think it actually even allows
charter schools to access that access
the expertise that would allow them to
access private
financing um I was going to stop there
um representative Tanner you asked a
question that
actually I would like to answer if I
could if it turns out that the chart the
charters are not made eligible for
building Aid I think this bill would
still actually be useful um um right now
what they have to do is they have to get
their own private financing so say a
which is obviously very difficult but
say a Char school was trying to do a
major
expansion they're still going to need
access to that expertise to to go get
the private financing so this would
actually still be helpful even if the
school B school um building Aid bill was
not to pass again I hope it does but if
it wasn't this would still be
helpful um again I appreciate your
consideration and I'm happy any
questions I can thank you very much yes
represent
Nelson forgive this ignorant question
here but is this money purely for ones
that are owned or ones that are rented
rent lease of space do they get to use
the money to do something around a
building their
leasing so it I don't think the bill
speaks to it um not obvious to me why
if you were leasing a building I would
actually think you'd want the the owner
to actually do that renovation um
because you you don't own it after that
right um but I I don't believe the bill
speaks to it that you you ask a good
question there my brain as we're
thinking about this was I was thinking
of owner
situations further
questions not seeing any hands up thank
you very much all right thank you yep
that's
it that's it on uh this bill
1685 uh we'll close the hearing and that
concludes the bills for
today
bu
you years if you pull out you got pay it
all back to
theate so what happens here if you get
this yeah that's a tough deal so they're
not going to go for the building a
because they they might pull out 10
years and then theying back if they
have